[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right
testing testing what's going on talk to
me people
a little early a little early vogue's
creep was going on
rico davis with the game great i know he
was a jeff fan that's that's what's up
i'm not a jeff fan though but
respect respect you know saint gangrene
kurt
yeah man we're going early kurt you saw
the lord's bend the knee to the nfl
so nfl season's here fantasy picks got
gotta be in your own time
so you know you know vocals with the
bills all right
it's all right okay that defense look
good i go for the quarterback look good
they got a good running back daniel
what's going on what's going on salute
let me know how my levels decide and
everything cool um
no addict this morning i think um pretty
sure addicts not gonna make it he's
gotta
work the double shift man so the lord is
in the bushes you know maybe we get a
sneak peek
cowboys chris the dawn for real okay
yeah y'all looking good though i got
that rookie
what's his name i got him on my fantasy
but it's something lamb cd lamb the one
that uh curved this girl at the draft i
got that one
yeah all right thank you vogel for the
vocals you know what i'm saying we're
just chilling
i saw a random earlier so i'm gonna hit
him up get him in here
you know king gonna pull up and do his
thing
and of course you know what i'm saying
colt eastwood we gotta make sure he's
good he's awake
thinking on the other side of the coast
but um yeah man i'm gonna catch up with
y'all in a minute we're good to see the
lords up in here early on a sunday
getting that that before nfl blessing
all right i'll speak to you on a minute
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
right now joining welcome to the round
lord silva you know what i'm saying the
finest always
dropping me with those nuggets right
quick man salute to the fight throw the
horns up in there for the finest y'all
salute miss and next time put it in the
show so you get the horns do it don't do
a pre-show do it in the show
so we're waiting for soft i don't know
if addy's gonna be here but we will
catch up with y'all in a minute
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh there's gonna be a spicy one oh man
and
we are live welcome to the iron lords
podcast and the lords of gaming.net
episode number 175 it's another glorious
sunday we're back at the round table on
the lord's day
i'm very excited about our special guest
and we've got the xbox series s
and x reveal info the impact of
the leaks ea play entering game pass
and the ps5 showcase to discuss so we
gonna get right into it
i want to introduce a lord who has not
only been one of the coolest supporters
in the room
but truly raises the ball with a
trifecta of high quality technical
analysis
superb video production and smooth
graphic quality
introducing the creating host of the
code eastwood youtube channel
and a panelist of the rdx podcast
the lord who is more than just gameplay
and reminds everyone it's just video
games
so be nice live from the state of
washington
and making his return into the realm of
the lords
my man lord colt eastwood how are we
doing sir
good thanks for having me on thank you
yeah you toxic
fan boys
yeah i spoke early what's going on here
um not much i'm really glad to be here
it's been a while and uh
it took you a long time to invite me
back
you know you know the iron lords are
always uh on strike because we don't
have our own interests so
you can join us behind the picket line
oh wow listen girl you know your family
brother
i figured you're busy all your
there's rdx open door and he can dm me
any time and i'm like cold
bring yourself you know this king when
you hit 100k because you know sometimes
some lawyers when they hit 100k
you know how they forget the hood they
forget where they came from i didn't
know if he was different
no incognito did he message me behind
the scenes i said um i don't know why
you're messaging me you need to message
my agent
yeah yeah my people speak to young
people people
i don't know why you're asking me
what's good uncle man good to have you
brother like what you've been playing
man which is good
uh i've been playing a bunch of stuff
i've been playing uh trying to get into
marvel avengers
and i've been playing um grounded
wow crazy enough as it is a game that i
wouldn't even ever touched
um and i've been playing that tony hawk
like
trying to remember old 1999 colt you
know oh yes
not too much facial hair yeah
yeah really enjoying it no doubt that's
what that's a snoop eastwood coat
good to have you in the room brother and
of course we have a lord who is no
stranger to the realm of the iop
and the mere mention of his name is
totally synonymous with rational
thinking
informative industry videos and an
honest passion for the xbox brand
introducing the creating host of the
random thor
youtube and oh hold on shut up middle
lane what's up here
and what half of the xbox 2 podcast
the non-filmic 60 frames per second
gamer
and the exposure of fake insiders on
social media
live from the south side of the shah and
making his return into the realm of the
lords
my man lord ran down thor how are we
doing sir
what is going up mr uh what do i call
you now lord unlocked
yes
yeah um i think i picked a good episode
to be on because i know
king's going to bring it today and he's
going to be in rare form and i am
here for that i am definitely here for
that but
you know i just want to say um yes that
cold east was amazing
yes one of the best youtubers out there
he's a great friend
and i am happy that we're actually on
the
iron lords podcast together we don't
really get a chance to
do podcasts that much but even though we
talk every single day but uh
it's great it's great to be on here with
you buddy yeah i appreciate it yeah it's
good i'm glad
yeah i said you better be up you better
be out of bed randall
i was just like please read don't over
sleep please
that's all i was nervous i was like red
sleeping sometimes i mean it says 10 am
like what the heck is going on
i don't get up this early but i got up i
got up this early for you i appreciate
him so i appreciate you man what you've
been playing brother
uh the game that the game that one
how do i say this uh the game uh the
game that one you play
everybody loves everybody loves this
game when they play it
aka the uh the game lower rated than
battletoads uh marvel avengers
remember remember once when people said
that cult that it's lower than battle
toads
uh it's like a 60 on xbox 67 68
on playstation i can't i i can't play it
we'll get into that later
yeah sorry i've been playing that um
some parts are good and some other parts
are very bad
mm-hmm and uh i also been playing among
us nice i love
hearing things about that yeah it's uh
if you have a really good group of guys
together or
gals it can be a pretty fun game nice
but i think i reached my limit with that
game
like the last time i played it i found
it incredibly boring
uh but i we did a we did play it like
five days in a row so
it's pretty cool it's a nice it's a nice
little five dollar game and it's a nice
like change of pace
so no doubt no doubt no attic is not
planning a wwe interest
alexander we're gonna get it to add yeah
they think it is happening they really
that's why we need though
let's get that
we don't have the four horsemen of
gaming we have the three hospital gaming
one of our horsemen
is out so uh shout out to adam he does
have a legit excuse i know y'all don't
believe him
but he does have a legit excuse the boy
has to work a double shift the man was
trying to stay awake he's like
could you call me i'm on the road i
don't want to say i got you bro so
salute to the bro
he look at the fraud alerts come on no i
did i didn't agree i did speak to him
last night
and all that is definitely true because
you know he only calls me when he's up
at night and i was like oh you messed up
right he's like
yeah don't lie to the people this is the
dude that stayed up three days straight
to play final fantasy 7. i don't want
i don't wanna hear it all right that
that part he'd be fraud yeah but he
wouldn't end the game yeah
this is attic's world remember that
totally forget
it it's important to him exactly yes we
give one addict's world emoji and then
we move on
anyway and of course we have our most
technical gaming lord
the solo game who lives for the single
player selfish experience
and also testosterone mr offline profile
illuminati and lower patreon of the iron
bank
my man lord sofrien how are we doing sir
uh
i'm hold on a second what's up
oh oh good morning good morning sir good
morning
ah that man like 11 a.m
you're a fan of the time switch sir oh
baby i got the mimosas on deck too let's
go
we got the verboses let's go let's talk
about what's going on bro
a pleasure to be here this morning with
you it's fine morning yes
oh yeah it's good no doubt i'm doing
pretty good oh before i move on though
first of all it's welcome to the realm
the finest
official put the horns in the chat i
wasn't on so you know i have to come up
and say it
yeah and put the horns in the chat then
we have a three four dollar super chat
from night music
with a nice coffee mug too so i'm sure
he's appreciating 11 a.m
um yeah and i haven't played a damn
thing this whole week thank you
bro what's going on you always playing
working working hard in the bushes not
even any switch man nothing
no doubt no doubt we'll get to a lot to
talk about and
of course everyone's been waiting for
this we have the incredible hulk of this
aka the access caver ooh
the lord of commvas fought king of the
statues
if there's nothing less than that
premium experience it is the leader of
the fraud alert
movement beloved and
highly anticipated lord king how we
doing sir
are you ready
or you ready
let's go what's up man feel
dominance maximus real quick
really a spencer we got a really
surprised we got a really
really is i don't know you might want to
wait till everybody wait till after
wednesday
can we wait until after wednesday no no
no no
no no no no no no you're gonna put some
respect on my man name right now
i'm not waiting for nothing playstation
is doing y'all gonna stop that right
there
fearless i don't know why why they in
that box
i told you what he was gonna do with the
pencil attack
you don't have power and you don't have
price i don't care what you do
there's nothing you're doing is getting
out of that
you know why he got aurelius because it
was your 25th anniversary when my man
went butt bananas
oh he shouted on their birthday
disrespecting all day
it was trending he went to your funeral
and kicked over your casket
my man is out here rocking you and i
don't care
what you're talking there's no gameplay
he's waiting for you to
show all your hand and gonna knock you
smooth out
so all y'all talking about oh
playstation's been quiet you can't talk
with a bloody mouth
your mouth is bloody so i don't know i'm
not being friend
i'm not talking all that oh you know
playstation you got to be nice it's
about game
i don't care phil dominus maximus
spencer no phil dominance maximus are
really
really his kids and y'all already know
he watched i cannot wait until we do
that live show
because after that live show you all
already know there's another show for
xbox
and why is that why is that so
king of pixel big g concurs with you
with the 2 super chat 299 series s
plus game pass good night and god bless
y'all come on red can we get some
sensitivity
i'm gonna let king have his moment that
was just my intro and let me explain
what i've been playing this week
hold
to my shock and my amazement drake's
hollow
is inside game pass that's the game that
we saw on the floor
got the interview with the developer yes
and the game
is utterly amazing in its final form
resident evil 7 is in game pass
definitely touching that up
but i want to give a shout out to green
mason um because he got sick and tired
of me fraud
and not picking up um marvel avengers
he got tired of you i'm telling you bro
that you love hulk like
that isn't pectoralis major oh you're
not feeling
hulk running around looking like me in
the chest um
i disrespectful boy i said okay
okay so i'm looking at him like when i
first saw it first of all to me the game
is fantastic i don't like too much of
the blur effect i wish i could take it
off
but um when i saw the hulk
i'm like why is he bruised up like that
like what the hell is going on
and i said it looks like it's like when
a tall muscle because when i tore my
muscle
it looked like that then i'm looking at
his chest piece and then i started
looking at all the other skins
i said yo his chest on those chest is
right i said
why are you getting my way in the beat
up chest piece i saw i was pissed off
with that because i'm stuck with this
chest piece
beat up hulk until i can get a better
spin
and that's the only part if if that's
the only part i'm mad at you know it's a
damn good game
but that's the only part i'm mad at it
is the hulk uh it is a nice
grounded take on revenges
um if you haven't tried it or if the
demo is up or whatever's still up try it
out um
whatever anybody's telling you don't let
nobody decide what your food tastes like
you taste your food factual
factual no doubt and of course we have
the gaming ninja himself the shinobi
lord
oled himself spreading that realness to
the remnant iop
now tell you what you want to hear but
what you need to hear
what's popping brand new oled locked in
4k 120 what's rocket yo
yo we gotta talk about it man what's up
cole what's up man
i'm gonna descend i've got a b8s now
you're making me all jealous i need to
get a cx now man
i i got 1080p at at 120 but not 4k
but you know what dealer told me to buy
that back in what year was that cold
2018 the dealers spend my money
right now dealer loves spending our
money right
yeah i mean you're crazy if you're not
buying a brand new tv every year
yeah dealer's trying to get me to buy a
brand new pc too so
i just bought one hey i'm telling you
the same things yeah that is your spot
yeah that's true you gotta spend money
to make money you rich youtuber over
there
i only got 150 000 views on my last
video oh
[ __ ] oh shots view shaving against the
great coal
we're doing that oh my god
yo man that thing is glorious like oh
man
just first i want to shout out some
lords shout out to lord jay fonzarelli
who
actually took the time gave me some
great advice for salute to him
everything that's going on with his
family and everything like that that's
my bro
just it was so good to hear his voice we
talked on the phone and he was just like
man
and then you know just got over life
stuff and then we started talking about
gaming stuff and then um
yeah he hooked me up he was like cog
make sure this settings right this i
also want to shout out um six layer with
giving me some information in reference
to freesync and some
slight issue with um the xbox one x and
which setting to mess with
so i was just playing around man yo
first thing off the bat
see you thieves jesus lord oh
man like i've never cared about that
game that much until now
that thing looks amazing obviously dusty
had to put through the paces just to see
the different areas
the illuminate when stuff goes from like
a dark area to a well-lit
i don't if this i don't even know what
know what ray tracer look like put it
that way because
this is non-rain tracing stuff so if ray
tracing amplifiers or makes any of this
stuff look
even better it's truly amazing so shout
out to that
um dolby vision oh man and deep blacks
and
oh let me say something let me see
something since you're since you're
getting you're talking about tv and porn
right now
um don't let somebody tell you how good
looking their games look when they're
running like a 1987
venus oh are you implying what king is
saying that we should listen to these
tcl games no you definitely should not
listen to these tcl gamers
thank you come on now now i have a tcl
in the other room that
for 500 bucks that's a great tv but you
know don't get all up on your high horse
when you
tcl gamers got that uh got the ps4 slim
in the xbox one
they got the xbox vcr
yo the thing look absolutely amazing um
also
4k blu-ray i threw on black panther
man there you go
that's the thing with hdr right like hdr
10
doesn't have the full color gamut like
it just doesn't do adobe vision does so
i
and it's funny like that xbox bent in
the inside you know what we're going to
give you guys
this licensing fee and we're going to
because it's just
it's night and day and then who's the
only one that has it
is it confirm they said first that's the
i
let me let me defer the quote cole what
do we know so far about dolby vision
because the la the lingo i got was that
when dolby made the announcement
they said first on xbox oh is it an
exclusive thing do we know if piece five
is not having it
you know you're the first i didn't hear
the words first on that but
console's coming out in two months they
would have said by now
um yeah there is some i looked into this
dolby vision quite a bit over the
past year or so and uh you know it
dynamically changes the hdr based on the
scenes you're always getting the best
hdr
at all times so it is far superior so
the
pairing atmos on any set any headset or
any
sound system will work with dolby atmos
at its best
and then you get dolby vision like and
then
the series x is the most powerful like
you've got a really good set
for playing just about every single game
so it's gonna be really nice
i don't know what they're if they're
planning on bringing that playstation
later
yeah uh i think the pl the ps4 pro and
the ps4 were rocking dolby
5.1 i think most of the generation while
the xbox was using
7.1 yeah right playstation though i mean
i threw on ghosts on there
i threw on a couple other games it
looked phenomenal i adjusted my hdr
settings
on my ps4 looking great um shout out to
the switch even the switch look kind of
good i was doing more of you
it looked better than it ever looked all
just like okay all right switch you want
to look good
i was expecting the worse from them the
only thing about the oleds is the only
thing that has me sort of like and you
haven't talked to you about the hot
either it's just the the brightness
the brightness yeah well yeah that's my
little thing and we'll i'll get off the
topic soon but um
because i was going back and forth with
fonz and he's like game mode and
whatever whatever
but i'm like it's muting my colors i
like it popping you know
so we we're having this philosophical
debate
and i can understand like there's the
purists are gonna want that more i know
you soft you're a purist
you i don't yeah it ain't mold in the
bushes yeah yeah yeah
he hates me i know i know so we already
know
my oh yeah the oled is you know that's
that's
at the the he said it's a good tv would
it make the switch good look good
i know that's a fantastic last point
i'll say is um
i'm really excited now because of the tv
code like i'm so hyped
anytime i hear like there's a 4k 120
hertz game
like like a rainbow six siege ori
like like oh what's the dirt all roses
getting comments your question is that
um formulating your purchase uh list
oh yeah that's wonderful okay so so
the television is dictating what games
you
you're going to purchase games that you
would have never looked at right
the only game he's going to end up
playing on is destiny 2.
we'll be playing a lot of that beyonce
beyond lights on game passer and you're
gonna be joining me you have those yeah
we'll see i can't believe saab is like
game mode is in the bushes like
every time i i like sometimes when the
tv doesn't like
flip to the right mode or like i change
it sometimes
yeah uh and then i play a game it's like
why does this
feel weird yeah like wow and then i look
like oh because it's not in game mode
but i will say this the the lg's are
getting closer and closer
to be able to give you the game mode
like the benefits of game mode
without affecting the picture quality
yeah but other ones like
it'll just it'll mute the colors and
it's like yeah it's running smoothly and
beautifully but i'm like
one thing i like about um tv this tv
snitches it'd be like
hdr on like it'll tell you if this game
have hdr or not
like it's fun but no it tells you the
frames per second it tells you
everything right
[Music]
finally finally okay hold on a second
we're going to scroll down a little bit
then we have a humble beast with the two
within two dollars with chat yes sir
pouring out a little liquor in my black
tux r-i-p-t-c-o
lord mods with the ten dollar superman
pln
uh ten dollars for the chat series let's
go whole gaming back
to the book shout out to vods
and gaming that that via messi in this
look to my bro
he's killing it right now man
then we
say it with me now cognorn rad good guy
surfer straight bushes
wow we're not doing that not even the
best hashtag not even a video
abstract
you do not know about server i had to
pull your card or your knowledge i could
tell you don't read the books
anyway then let's put those crusts in
the chat for a new member
knitter design put the horns up man put
the hands up
we got stitch with the five dollar super
chat first no time first no
time time that time change announcement
yes there were plenty of them
yes sir fraud alert on stitch you did
not pay attention we put the
addict in uniform and third tcl is
putting together a ceases to stand
shut up everybody so we're all caught up
so let's uh let's get real quick um we
got the
winners right we got some some bills
they got to pay real quick got some
doors we got to pay you know every month
we say thank you to our patreon
subscribers and our youtube subscribers
for
for for supporting us so let's get into
these giveaways yes sir
we have our 10 gift card giveaway for
the month of september
and that goes to
if you're listening uh and i don't have
any other contact information for you
please contact me at lordstop.iop on
twitter
and i will get you your code salute all
right
now oh hold on hold on hold on jay barry
you're here being messy
we're gonna have to get there let me get
that let me get shout out to the boogie
downs own
jay barry with the 297 chat i would love
king to read
happy playstation 5 oh no no matter king
my bad
you have to read this excuse me barbie
put this in for you
what do this it says is it color it's a
color don't try
happy playstation 5 showcase
announcement weekend
series s celebration is over
you know you know i
i do appreciate the fact that they said
something because you guys was in the
tears and buckets standing there with
snap bubbles in your nose
and i understand but don't be too happy
cause come wednesday you're gonna say
have the same face y'all had head today
the same face all you got is hope and we
dash that away
you don't have price and you don't have
power they can't change those two things
it's over here we go where's they gonna
be fun
oh and then we got we got somebody else
the guy before we left
we have tazowichi with the five dollar
super chat surfer has been a good hero
since the 90s
where no stories were great although
screaming quote was the best avatar and
ran how is the puppy
you got a puppy man no no uh i mean
we we rescued um oh don't worry
english mastiff a year ago but he was
already like
uh two to three years old at that point
i remember that little little guy
not a pup colt's got two puppies
i'm so manly when you say that
babies but yeah right now when we're
when we're stuck at home you know having
having a couple of
loyal dogs has been pretty nice you know
because the kids are ridiculous
okay so that we have our twenty dollar
gift card giveaway
oh no um our 20
gift card goes to
we got regulator 951
xbox hit me up salute yeah no oh what's
up what's up cd
you know what y'all what's going on 90
gang i see you bro you already know what
time it is he's up early up early what's
up
all right and now we have our teespring
giveaway all right
and our teespring giveaway goes to
who get the dread the medic
once again thank you to all our youtube
and patreon subscribers for all you guys
do for us
um it is amazing like i said week over
week day over day
you guys are constantly getting new
people into the realm so thank you so
much for the support
i truly appreciate much appreciate good
to see y'all up early man i know we we
sent out the message in the middle of
the week so salute to y'all for being up
early the lord's betting they need a
football and all that good stuff so
we're gonna get right into it man
does football bubble count though i mean
like this football bubble game
it counts because fantasy league started
i got money
i don't want to hear no fraud on that
absolutely i'm so upset
i'm like so upset football should not
come out
to michael aka fighters two dollars what
up king them ps dudes looking scared
okay all right last week's post in the
people spoken to the question with the
latest announcement and controversy of
super mario 3d collection
being a limited release port do you
think nintendo
fairly or unfairly gets a pass on these
practices
the winner of our three-way iop poll at
52
of the vote was yes pure greed
minimal effort and fake urgency by
nintendo
coming in at second place at 28 of the
vote was i don't care because it's going
to be on and popping when the zelda
remake versions come out
and then last place at 19 of the vote
was
this is not anything new nintendo is
just meeting demands of its
fans shout out to all the lords who
participated in the poll let's get our
resident nintendo
expert lord rand
how do i feel about the the mario 3d
stuff yes
uh i don't understand why anybody would
want to replace sunshine
first of all because that is a horrible
horrible game
and two like
if microsoft or sony did this where they
said hey
last of us 2 is only going to be
available physically individually
for halo infinite was only going to be
available digitally for six months
there would be riots in the stream
nintendo does it and everyone's like oh
that's cute or
nintendo being nintendo right i don't i
don't
nintendo just gets away with a little
bit more stuff than everybody else does
it seems
factual or or they'll be like why
why putting it on a limited demand or
whatever limited stock is
it's genius it's genius game that's
always the best one
right max max man yeah definitely switch
covered in hot with the scabs
salute you want to get uh george padilla
uh
we have george padilla with the ten
dollar super chat first time here get
getting einhorn sound effect for the
giveaway thanks fellas
brother yes sir you already know so
let's get right into it man we got a lot
of topics going
on lord sov you are
up looks like the internet broke
with some news apparently yes
ladies and gentlemen the cat's out of
the bag finally
microsoft has lost the game of chicken
through no fault of their own
um and uh after leaks which uh showed
the xbox series s
and its specs rather than deny them
microsoft decided to come out and say
yes this is the xbox series s and and
released the video that was introducing
the
the console to the world in addition to
uh its specs
not long after they gave the price point
which is 299 and we'll talk about that
in a minute
and then not long after that they
decided to give the price point for the
xbox series x
coming in at 4.99 and the release date
for both consoles which will be
tuesday november 10th 2020 boo on the
tuesday
i want the friday um so my question to
you gentlemen
is first off what do you think of the
series s
as a product in it of itself
what how do you think its place in the
marketplace affects what playstation is
going to be doing
uh next wednesday
and as a whole well no that that's
basically that's basically
say the link for me on the second topic
though okay
yeah so which which leak
well just the fact that it leaked itself
because i want to i want to touch on
that and be separate
absolutely okay yeah look let's get
right to it man let's get a little cold
in here man we know the news broke
obviously you know but now that it's all
out there all the information that's off
you know put out like what what are you
feeling man
what's your thought process on this uh i
talked about it for
almost two years it was crazy uh
thanks to uh rand and i talked about it
for a long time
we had an idea we had our hunches um
you asked how does this affect
playstation
um price is the biggest deciding factor
on buying a console
now a lot of people are going to argue
with me and it doesn't mean that the
xbox series s is going to outsell the
playstation
uh and it doesn't mean it could or that
it should
but it does mean that a lot more people
are going to jump on a next generation
xbox than they may
have before and when people go in
and it's not even impulse buy when
people go in and they know what the
value of xbox is with game pass
and with what that little box can do
with that black ugly circle on the side
of it
shout out to the boombox
um debt 299 price tag
at walmart or best buy or whatever
online that is
really really enticing and it's going to
move a lot of people
onto an xbox or have them add an xbox uh
to their gaming area yeah so that's
really what that means
no doubt now now call let me let me
double down with you like what about
the tech itself how excited are you
about the tech
that was announced specifically with the
s i am way more excited about the series
s
tech than a lot of the people talking
right now on social media that don't
know what they're talking about
this is um as mikey barra who
left xbox and isn't really a huge fan
of xbox it's like exactly the truth
right
he said on rdx podcast chat last week he
said
you're not yeah he said you're not
getting a
1440p box that can run up to 120 frames
for 300 you're not getting that on a pc
anywhere near a pc you're not getting
that on another console
it's amazing what it's going to do for
next generation games you're going to
see all these games a bunch of games
running at 60.
um everybody is going to stop
worrying so much about resolution count
the next generation and they're going to
be worrying about does it have ray
tracing does it also run at 60
does the hdr look really great yes um
there's going to be things that
more than just that overall count of
resolution and that's where the series s
shines because
it's so dirt cheap yeah it's going to be
a big deal point of entry so real quick
so how you doing kell you getting
you're getting both you're getting what
what you're looking at for you
personally
yeah i'm gonna be out of money
i am definitely buying a series s and x
the x will be my main i'll put it right
next there i'm gonna
to the uh the x i'll move the hdmi back
and forth once in a while to try it i
may not use it much
um but i want to have it and i'm also
getting the ps5 digital
because who needs a disc um so yeah i'm
getting the series s for sure
no doubt don't someone would get some
chats that we get ran in sure we have uh
speeder man with the five dollar super
chat
colt the naughty dog of youtube and ran
the ultimate insider on ilp
fire great true he loves the inside
attack keep calling random inside of
y'all
he loves that knowledge of all his hard
work
then we have everborn saga with the two
dollar super chat aaron greenberg says
only xbox has vision and atmos
interesting all right let's get it in
and shout out the hazard
we have one more we have cedric h with
the ten dollars with the challenge
good morning lord shout out to randon
colt listening and reading wolverine
hands on a dead body
wolverine
oh he said not an insider he's defending
red he's a veteran
stop memeing me bro you killing me right
now bro
that was what's up he got him like lined
up too
he'd be in his bag you know salute the
house he was killing me but yo
let's get right to it lord ran man now
that the news is out there the
information
that's got a chance to saturate a little
bit like where are you
at as far as you know both consoles the
announcement the price point
how you feeling um
i mean it's exactly what i expected it
to be know about it for
insider talk let's go i mean i've known
about i've known about series s for i
don't know how long at this point
i mean i i still recall like there was
that point where everybody thought it
was canceled and i remember
mean dealer pulled you aside and we both
were just like it was like
october i'm like this thing's still real
like we knew it was real like
so it's not a surprise realistically
it maybe was a surprise in the way
microsoft announced it obviously nobody
was expecting a tweet at two o'clock in
the morning to officially announce the
console
i don't think anybody expected them to
announce it all the way in september
i think it was supposed to be announced
earlier so that's a surprise
um the way it looks i would say the way
the form factor is a bit surprising like
i had always heard it was like
basically a shoe box and it really does
look like a shoebox
yeah um which which is impressive for
that system to be that small for the
you know the tech inside of it um i
think it was very important
for microsoft to hit 299 because that
was the play
like we knew series x was going to be
expensive and
this is their play to regain some market
share
um this generation in the united states
unite
in the united kingdom like i don't
really think
like i think regaining market share in
europe is probably a lost cause at this
at this point in time like
spain germany uh those places are like
firmly entrenched like you know
playstation nation
right but even this gen like the xbox
did
pretty well for the most part in the
united states there wasn't that big gap
like there is
elsewhere and especially now with the
way the economy is
and people out of jobs like this system
could really appeal to
i mean let's be honest the system is for
the group of
gamers who only really are interested in
playing call of duty or fortnite
or madden or fifa who don't really have
an allegiance to playstation or xbox who
don't care
about the halos or don't care about the
god of wars
and stuff like that like they're in it
be like i want to play
the big multiplayer the multi-platform
games or
the big mo the big multiplayer games
with their friends and price is more
important to them
is there like is that like a huge
audience potentially
like potentially series s could be uh
something that is you know disruptive uh
to the industry maybe it won't be i mean
i we we won't know until
you know the systems are out and what
the availability of these systems are
like i'm worried that when pre-orders go
live on the 22nd
yeah what's happening i'll miss it but
i'm going to be you know f5 and all
these different websites
man like i i think it's going to be i
have a feeling it's going to be these
systems are going to be very limited
and they're going to be people out there
who want to get them and who won't be
able to
right um so i think it was important for
for microsoft and their strategy against
playstation
uh they wanted to have the most power
which they achieved with the series x
and they wanted to have the cheapest
price
which they will there's no way sony's
going to match that at 299.
it really is um there's like there's
there's zero chance
i know i've seen some playstation guys
christopher hearts in there ray coming
at you
some playstation guys say that they'll
get the digital edition all the way down
to 299 and i'm like
you're smoking something just smoking
something if you think that's going to
happen
that's fair is also a little bit lower
than it really should be too
so remember that they're losing they're
probably losing a fair bit of money on
the series s
um as far as what playstation is what
playstation affected by
i don't think so because
i mean we've known if we've known about
it for a while i'd assume playstation's
known about it for a while
they probably guessed the price point as
well playstation just
it's it's like i was told like you build
this
you kind of like have a price point in
mind when you make these systems in the
first place
it's not just like you build a system
and then you're shocked like oh you know
like oh my god the system
with 700 what happened it's like no like
you have
you have a target in mind when you make
it so
i don't really think series s infected
sony
in any way shape or form they're gonna
price the system
uh to whatever they originally you know
built the system to do
like whatever they designed it for and
is it see the thing is i've always felt
and i know xbox fans maybe don't want
this but like
and maybe king won't like to hear this
oh uh but like sony can afford to be
less powerful and more expensive
right yeah like they are the more
popular worldwide brand
they definitely can and i hope they take
your advice
i hope right now they come out 599 to
550. i hope that
please listen to rand they won't be that
expensive but
but let me let me ask you this let me
back you up for a second right because
you're making some some great points
my question is if that is the case right
and we we do recognize them as the
global brand they're the market leader
from
you know the gen and everything we get
that but my question is so if that's the
case
and they have so much cachet i guess my
question is
why them specifically engage in any type
of
game of chicken when they've been so
dominant and just say yo this is what we
are
you know what i mean kind of thing i
guess that that's my question to you why
do you think that
i think maybe i think the game of
chicken potentially had more to do with
series x than series s
because there there might have been some
line of thinking that like
sony may have thought series x might
have been more expensive
so then they could have undercut like
a potential 600.6 series x and then they
could have had the ps5 come in like
and then and then if they offered the
ps5 for 500 it would look
really good in comparison so i think
that
i think that's where more of the game of
chicken
was going on plus i i really do think um
uh you know the pandemic affected
everything
yeah um i know sony was hesitant
at least from what i was told to talk
about price and release date until they
knew
for sure what the launch lineup was
going to be which is why
and that's one of the reasons why it's
taken this so long
because up until recently it wasn't
locked into what games were launching
with the system so
now we're two months away sony has a
better idea of
when these games are launching so now
they're confident enough to be like all
right
we know x games coming you know x day so
it's like now we can announce
uh the price we can announce the release
date and get every and get the ball
rolling
and i would think a lot of that also has
to do with like microsoft you saw
they lost halo right which is a huge
huge loss
yeah but they work with their partners
to kind of try to they kind of
i'm not going to say they tried to cover
it up right like
there's a big hole in the ground and
they kind of like threw some leaves on
top of it to make it look like it wasn't
like
i like that they they launched now
you're launching the series x
with destiny 2 with the expansion on
that day
with the upgrade in game pass right yes
essence creed valhalla moved their game
up a week to launch with the console
dirt 5 moved delayed their game to
launch
with the console so microsoft worked
with their partners
to essentially launch more games with
the system
to make a little bit more gears tactics
as well right yeah
make it a little bit more appealing
because of the halo infinite uh wasn't
going to be there you know
right no facts these these are these are
fantastic places all right i know we got
a couple of children
some chances that we get king if you uh
got that yeah hold on a second we got
stitch with the five dollar sweet chat
the leak could potentially hurt xbox
just because ps5 price was rumored to be
600. i hate leaks he takes away
from the old crap moment reaction that
is true
um and we have gerald mack with the five
dollar super chat shout out to the ilp
good morning
uh rocking with the heavy hitters
randall thor 19
and co colt beastwood
i just want y'all to know he is the
humblest man
in the world trust me when cole reached
out i was like yo [ __ ] what's up and i'm
like
i got you bro you're right you're right
it's been oh it's been a while you know
what's that you've been read tell me
like
i'm like yeah my bad i'm i just assume i
just assume you guys have been
weak to have us absolutely you just you
you did talk to me about a month ago
month ago and you said hey when this uh
lockhart stuff comes out
let's do the show and yeah there you go
needles just been too busy rubbing the
shoulders
the superstars you know the little guy
here we go here we go man get on a lot
one time and this is what i get
[Laughter]
selena for being messy but yeah man a
lot of stuff going i had to have you
both for him because again i want to
shout you two out before i pass over
king because
you guys you guys have kept me in line
as far as
what this price most likely is going to
be you know what i'm saying
and you guys have been on the money so
salute to you guys i see the videos
it's the only two price points that ever
made any logical sense
like i remember being on here um back in
december like right after the game
awards
uh if you recall remember like the game
rewards uh they revealed the system
that was when i that was when i said
horizon zero dawn was coming for pete
coming to pc and playstation nation he
met
remember when playstation remember when
jay barry came at my neck
yes
jay barry is my guy though so no he
already know those knees i got those
right there on ice
yeah but um i i said that because i
remember because i cuz i listened back
to that episode and
like there's a few people concerned that
like the systems would be
599 and 399 and like come on guys
like these systems it was it was only
ever going to be 299 and 4.99
so i mean like i called i mean
right am i am i wrong i am i so sick and
tired of hearing
the xbox scorpio is going to be 800 and
then it turned into
series x is going to be 800 or a
thousand and i just
i don't know i mean the only thing that
we could do at that point would say is
the series x really going to be 500 or
they're going to go for 400 because 500
isn't
like really a great price point for
moving a lot of consoles but
microsoft doesn't care people say cole
are they gonna undercut sony are they
gonna
they're gonna move the price i'm like no
they have no reason to move the price
they have series
s series s is the price winner series x
is the power winner
that's all they have to do and then they
have to bring uh xbox game studios up to
speed which starts
next year yeah shout out to uh shout out
to addict and uh forte for taking out oh
they gotta take the hounds hundreds
yo shout out to emma
they've been pushing that 600 narrative
and i'm like
no bro stop thank you for saying that
ram yeah yeah i mean yeah
i i'm sure forte will talk about in the
you know the
10th podcast
because at the end of the day another
part of prior to this lead up right code
was that
the whole whole rhetoric that yo as the
lockhart doesn't exist remember that
that was strong for a minute cold so
again
yeah i mean there's there's a semi maybe
a
former prominent member of the gaming
community on twitter that called me a
liar
yes like a year and a half ago so colt's
out here lying about this lockhart
and i talked about um i think it was
right at the beginning of 2019 after i
had reported about lockhart a couple
times
i said that it could be one of the
things that helps xbox come up
and do have a really great generation
because
it was i mean we had been hearing that
if this thing existed and it was about
the power of the 1x
um what it is now it was going to be 300
and with that price point it was going
to sell a lot more than
any xbox one was selling so dude
called do you remember and i even said
this back in that december show
i was like people were like well what
are they going to do with the 1x i'm
like it's going to be discontinued
oh yeah and then and then what happened
it was discontinued
it was so confused you know what's weird
like
like as soon as this like kotaku ran
that
hit piece about the naming thing it's
like oh people would be confused and i'm
like
and i thought to myself like wait a
minute there's literally two switches on
the market
switch and switch light facts and one of
them doesn't even freaking switch
it's just
and people seem to understand exactly
what each one of them does
i've gotten a comparison that really
ticks people off because they don't like
me comparing a car to a console but
the the honda civic has been putting out
the dx
and the ex and the si for
30 years at least 25 years and no one's
come home with a honda civic
dang it i bought the base model
the problem the problem isn't two skus
the problem
the people people don't have a problem
with multiple skus people have a problem
with xbox oh
bias against excellent wait hold on i
got i gotta say something else that
people don't say
playstation has the best naming
convention because they're just go one
two they have a linear naming convention
if you don't if you ignore
the slims and the pros and the ones
they've done along the years
theirs is the most simple but they kind
of have one of the only products in the
market for
mostly anything that goes in a
sequential number the iphone and
galaxies are wacky numbers
the nintendo ds tvs forget about if you
can't figure out that an s
is the base model and x is the high end
model of an xbox
don't even go shopping for a tv because
at this point playstation is one of the
very few products on the market that has
a sequential numbering system and i know
people are going to come up but there's
this there's there's this brand of forks
i buy that goes by number three
if you think about if you think about
all the products that we buy
all over our house and outside the world
for whatever
yeah there is not very many products
that run like
oh i'm going to get this i'm going to
get the fork 7.
playstation has a great name convection
convention
convention and it is one of the very few
products
most every product on the market i'll
just repeat myself doesn't use a linear
naming convention they use
different names and you just look at a
box yeah yeah
what does it have and when you go to
walmart or best buy or target or
look online when you get to that page or
you're at the store there's a little
white panel there that says series s
or one s and it has like a checklist and
then the x as a checklist
you get the same thing like it's just
people are rand's right i just
ranted for four minutes for nothing
right people have a problem with
xbox so they're coming up with a reason
to to uh
concern troll and they look like clowns
i mean concerns
because like look at any product has any
product has multiple variations i mean
cognito bought a cx bro were you
confused between the cx the bx the ex
the 55 inch the 48 inch why didn't you
get
is the lg b series better than the c
series because b
is better a would be the best or or is
b last year's model and c is the new one
and the next one will be d
like so let me let me play a little bit
of a little bit of a devil
oh uh oh playstation nation stand it up
let's go south
i don't know not at all but this is it
all right so
when they when we first started talking
about the essa and and what it can do
right i guess people's assumption
maybe it's wrong of them to assume that
um that the s
is better than the one x in every
way imaginable right but when you look
at what it can do like it can't do 4k
right
and they and if if you're going to do
okay
no no it'll so it's not 4k though
what you just said the playstation pro
is not 4k either but i didn't see it
uh series s can't right that's one thing
so you might
somebody coming from a 1x assuming that
maybe the s
is more powerful than the one x might
not be right 100
right two when it comes to back compact
games right
right when it comes to your back and
pack games you're going to be playing
the s
versions of that right rather than the x
versions right
so that's one of those things that i i
think they need to make clearer
that the one the series s is
the upgrade to the 1s right because
there's been
some language that indicates like hey
this box is better than the one x in
most every way
so it'd be it'd be easy for some people
to be like okay if it's better
do you really think that the person that
purchases x right now
is the person that's purchasing an s no
that's a different kind of consumer
right consumer is looking at a series x
right but their own language has said
that this box is better than the 1x in
most every way
so if if you're somebody who had the one
x right for whatever reason and you're
not
you're not impressed or whatever you
don't want to go to the series x and
you'll get what you're paying for
that though and you didn't do your due
diligence you get exactly what you came
that why why do you think that is the
case
if it is a better box why doesn't it do
those things well i mean
well one one x is discontinued so i mean
like we're gonna be able to buy it
anyways
two while it can't do 4k cause it was
designed to be
1080p 1440p machine which by the way
it'll be more of a 1080p machine and it
will be a 1440p
machine but like i agree it is it's all
going to do its own enhancements like
the 1x was just brute forced to do 4k in
a lot of cases right they just threw in
a better gpu and it was still held back
by the cpu and all that stuff
this game and we thought gears 5 run 120
frames yeah the 1x could never run gears
5 120 frames right well it could but you
would have to drop the resolution really
low right right yes probably going to
run
at 60 frames on on the series s
not going to run at 60 frames on the 1x
right right because
it's gonna have its own set of
enhancements not to mention like fast
loading
with the ssd so i guess it really
depends on what you consider
better like do you consider the 4k
resolution better or the frame rate
enhancements
better right um but in my mind the
consumer that is
concerned about that like that has a one
x would be upgrading to the series x or
the steering x and the consumer would be
who
is the one asked would be upgrading to
the series
what i'm doing is being objective unlike
some people on this podcast
you're not being objective at all you're
just thinking a consumer that
he's actually he's actually saying what
a lot of people have been saying
uh which they sound reasonable but
rand's breaking it down really well
the series s is actually better
than the 1x in almost every way just
exactly as you said
right um now as far as the back and pat
you can say well the back and pat's not
better
this is the reaction
[Applause]
about tcl owners oh so that that whole
demographic is going to actually serious
4k anyway so i mean what are you really
talking about
so we're going to shoe rocks the whole
demographic
let me just say something real quick
okay about this whole back and fast
stuff with the series s i see a lot of
a lot of guys who aren't interested in
xbox
who talk about xbox all day long right
um
and i'm just going to say and these are
guys that have said who buys consoles
for
back and pat stuff right we don't buy we
don't buy consoles for old games blah
blah blah which
i tend to agree with because i don't use
back and pat but i like the idea of mike
the games i buying actually moving
forward with me even if i don't use them
whatever but
my point is you have these guys who
don't care about xbox and won't buy
their consoles suddenly
really concerned that the series s is
going to
run the back compact versions of the 1s
i'm just going to ask a simple question
are you going to keep that same energy
when the playstation 5
back and pat is shown off and if it is
way worse than the series s like let's
say that let's say the playstation 5
back and pass strategy
sony comes out and be like bro we only
got a hundred games launching with back
and forth i wonder if those same guys
who gave the [ __ ] sorry for the bad word
the series asked for the
for the back and pat will they have that
same energy for sony if their back and
pass strategy isn't up to par
are you or will they suddenly be
completely silent
we'll find out soon enough you don't
know what exactly is on the ps5
i'm buying a ps5 day one i don't know
exac i don't even know what's going on i
also don't even know exactly what's
going on
with the xbox because there's more i
mean people have been dming me like
crazy about this there's more to the
story about
the xbox series console back compat than
just saying well
the ram pool in the series s is only 7.5
and that's not enough for a 1x
enhancement there's way more to that we
had bill stillwell on rdx
like three months ago he said they have
select titles
we don't know anything about how many or
how many games are going to get this
treatment but
the software engineered enhancement on
bat compat is now seeing games
that are unlocking frame rate without a
patch from the developer and i don't
know if that means one or two games
i don't know if it means a lot of games
or if bill stilwell is trying to say
they've
got a lot of games running this we have
no idea so there's way more to the story
so people could be out here concerned
trolling about
xbox one s versions of games on series s
and then by the time this thing comes
out we're gonna start seeing a bunch of
games that get automatically patched
almost in the same way we may see ps5
backward compatibility work
where they use the hardware to boost the
games so they look better than they did
on the ps3
yeah okay so i'll get that get your
point off and then super chat please
yeah let me go and then
i can go um so to that point
what what court was just talking about
um after the announcement of the
s man i saw so many podcasts and i'm not
going to shout out the podcast because i
don't want to shout them out name them
[ __ ] shave the devil we're not doing
that
dude that's king one particular
playstation center podcast said i'd just
leave it at that station
podcast talking about xbox oh my god
unbelievable
but it was like it was one of those
things like look i like to be objective
and this was one of those things where
it's like they
couldn't they couldn't even just
directly say look this is
100 positive about it it was everything
that they said about it
the the counter points were ridiculous
like sort of ridiculous like
creating scenarios just don't happen um
little timmy little timmy's back again
it was just like it was bad man i was
like i've never
i've never had to turn off a podcast
like that i was like wow this is crazy
um so objectively objectively the value
proposition of the s
is absolutely fine
and and the thing about it is like when
you when you when you take into
consideration the all asset
the all access aspect of it facts
in a lot of ways uh i think colt
mentioned this earlier like he
he doesn't he doesn't necessarily see it
as an impulse buy right but i really do
see the people that are purchasing the s
are people that are gonna go buy it
point of sale
one shot with all access i think once
you
measure the two most people who are on
the fence
and thinking about getting an s if they
choose to go the old access route that
ten dollar difference a month
more often than like than not i believe
is going to push them towards the x
right because if i'm i'm paying 25 bucks
a month and i'm like well
for ten dollars more i can get the
considerably more powerful console
why don't i just do that right the s
serves so many different purposes in
this marketplace
that i think it's absolutely bonkers
that anybody could shoot down
this value proposition in any way shape
or form what i will say about somebody
who
who is maybe went over the playstation
this this time around and then but but
is willing to look at what microsoft is
doing this generation and say what
what's going on right if they if
playstation manages to bring that all
digital console to 400
which i don't think i'm not sure that
they can do that but if they if they're
willing and managed to do that
that hundred dollar difference maybe
doesn't mean as much to that person in
that particular scenario right
beyond that though the s is appealing to
everyone else
everyone else in a way that's kind of
bonkers like
um and then uh listen i i another thing
that pissed me off was just
all of these like now all of these are
listen
the armchair developers oh we back on
that again oh lord yeah
listen and i'm not a dev i don't know
the details of this stuff
i don't know it but it's just like
once again you walk away from that one
dev that was talking that
i've been saying this for years right
and again i don't know how this works
per se
but developers have been scaling games
forever
i don't i don't want to get into the
design argument
my argument is completely separate
90 of the games you're going to be
playing are third-party games
the facts have to be the scale for the
lowest common denominator that's lower
than the s and the lowest common
denominator is
the lowest possible pc configuration you
can find that's the lowest possible
denominator
which they account for so again and
what i would like to know is and again
if somebody knows we've been saying for
the longest time these consoles
are basically pcs now right so there's
the it be fine for somebody to assume so
if they're basically pcs now then
the development process should be
basically almost the same right
is that not true right why are people
coming out saying no
we have to account for this we have to
account for that it's different they're
making it seem like it's different on
console
than it would be on pc that the way
these things would scale is different
so which one is it are these consoles
like p pcs
are they still really built in this
really bespoke manner that
requires them to be addressed
differently than you would a pc port
right there's a lot of questions going
to be asked at the end of the day i'm
not going to do the dev talk here
i'm not i leave that for lord dealer
lloyd cole all you guys
um at the end of the day this is what i
say let the game speak
let the game speak if if if the s ain't
hitting 120 frames
if we start hearing reports you know
what i'm saying of stuff then we get
into us all we gotta get these super
chats then we gotta get kicked
okay
[Music]
i got him hopefully i got him hold on no
no no
the chat is hilarious no worries no
worries okay first we got michael aka
bedsize finance with two dollar super
chat
on guarding them let the king speak
coming up come down he's coming
then we have speeder map our five dollar
super chat we need a fact checker group
for gaming journalists ign says the
the series s is faster than the ps5 and
the xbox resist is the same as the xbox
one x it's ridiculous
look i'm i'm the lord of unlock now we
ain't gonna do that
i mean we won't know until we get the
teardown of that playstation right or
wrong i mean
tell the truth i mean the fact the facts
are that the cpu
is faster oh whatever
it's been it's been debunked but we'll
get into that
uh we got megatron the phone jack
what's up iop great guest today you guys
are entertaining as
always thank you brother salute then we
have atl with the 10
super chat microsoft does jordan
gambling at the back of the plane with
thousands of dollars
playstations and dudes up front on the
playing gambling with just dollars
please don't go for the back of the book
last dance shave damn damn
then we have tony bryant with the ten
dollar super chance up iop hate that i
missed the first half a little too early
for my knees
you guys are doing side note getting a
tcl for the kids room my wife would
murder me if i bought another lg
but you have one sir you have one
my favorite name to say ever whipple
gaggins
hey series x is 750 in australia
the xbox one damaged the xbox brand to
the point where it is popular to dump on
it for basically anything
then we have pixel bit g with the five
dollar super chat sony uh
ps sad question do any of you trust only
to respect your digital purchases enough
will your library from ps4 all come over
will ps6 support
number five yeah that that's one of
those like levels
it's kind of the same gamble you take
when you do nintendo digital right like
isn't it i don't know
and make sure that you purchase the
playstation with the disc
you don't have confidence we know
king freedom yeah then we have uh we
have noob cybot 45.
in the building with the five dollar
super chat there's no way the
playstation backup pack would be as good
they would need to update every game
manually not happening
that's jonathan b with the five dollar
superchat and all we need is for tcl to
create
all access programs so y'all can play
2001 for hbo
damn johnny come on bro
hold on we got jumped out we got i got
barry
barry the game spoke for xbox craig says
hi
let me get aquaman
is there going to be a trade-in your 1x
towards your series x deal for a
discounted price i believe in the middle
yeah neo geo i mean neo geo neo sport
game spark has said that um
after i think it was like six months or
something you get the option are you
talking about the all access program
yeah i believe so yeah yeah yeah if
you're part of the oil access program
here if you're not part of the old
you're not calling microsoft up telling
them come take your access
yeah we got whimwow 200
wow will me thank you my brother wow
the only thing xbox is holding back is
youtubers with fake concerns trying to
grab it
you sound like rand will be you sounded
like red will reds rub it off for you
[Laughter]
then we have restored hades with the
five dollar super chat xbox series x is
going to be more impactful because ps5
is not going to be launching globally
and it's knowing that they're going to
have limited true fine
the devil oh my god so we all caught up
all right look let's get king has waited
long enough
here we go let's get it cake what are
you feeling you know
it's all the announcements oh oh oh he
brought the shirt out
okay what's that oh he had it made yeah
to me
see it right there scorpio
this is where it's this is where it
started it's
it's a monster okay okay that's where it
started this is
this is where he's he started his
journey who did that this is where
phil dominance is where he got dominance
from
remember he got maximus when he did uh
game pass okay okay
okay he got a really is when he stomped
your head to the curb
phil dominus maximus are really
expensive
put some respect on his name he brought
respectability back to the house of
microsoft
the dawn is gone because the don was
trying to tear stuff up shout out to the
donna terry myerson
um satya
that's my man's back should i open the
book of exercises
see you you dudes don't know exactly
what one
last generation for you
people with goldfish memory
i'mma let you know what won price point
power and being available
now you don't have price
phil check that off
he told you from the rip he looked you
in your eyes and said
we will be the most powerful
check that off who did that for you
so um they're launching
globally availability
check that off that's the collection
plate around y'all faster collecting so
now now now
now playstation must have forgot
oh roy jones
we we slipped on a banana pill you gotta
lay up we laid up we patrick hewn we
finger roll we messed up
we messed up somebody at the last minute
thought connecting a box was a good
thing
somebody said yo let's divert power to
the connect
let's put this big giant vcr box to the
people
tell us let's let's release
in limited spaces
okay since of the past is going to be
revisited
mm-hmm by this boss that's in charge
right now
playstation right now y'all you're
trying to figure out you're saying no
king they're gonna they can't beat price
i'm gonna give you some undeniable facts
right now they can't beat
price it's over so we know where you're
going
why we know where they going because
they go for the cheapest
i know you i know you you
fry they do i know you so the black
friday tcl
phil was this was the point of the time
that's what we're doing
i told you he was coming for you he got
you you already got
okay also also for the kid
for the kid that thought he was getting
a playstation five mm-hmm
when your mom's in your pocket
oh my god oh my god go to the store they
don't care about your playstation
[Music]
sick and tired of financing your hobbies
you're sick and tired of digging in
their pockets and your grades ain't good
enough
they sick and tired of you thinking the
world revolves around you you
know what they give you so
it's funny how he's not even big up in
the s
you know why because listen i'm picking
up four consoles i'm picking up and two
acts
of x y'all but
for those power hungry dudes for those
dudes that was talking resolution and
all that chit chat
before are you getting two s's so you
can put them together
oh no no no no no no no
in my non-gaming rooms like if i'm down
in the man cave
in in other situations yes um
for you powerful hungry dudes let's go
for you dudes that was talking
resolution remember that resolution
remember that remember digital foundry
y'all was all over did you y'all made
digital foundry hot
power changer situation
funny huh you're talking about 120 talk
y'all shut up
shut up y'all don't got 120 in your box
shut up they do got dirt kick
listen listen listen they got 30 frames
per second
filmic vision what the hell
they were talking about filmic vision
listen when
the leak came out i first of all i
believe it was strategic
because that's just me i know
and then microsoft three o'clock in the
morning sends out a tweet who's up three
o'clock in the morning
yeah shout out to them yeah they were
right all over that they said yeah this
is true this is that's
that's the word that's the word the word
is
november 10th locked and loaded go get
that
and also yes sir get your pre-orders on
september 22nd take a day off work they
gave you enough time to take a day off
work so you could be next to your pc
refreshing your cart
oh hold on hold on get in your stuff
it's not in color but he said is he ever
going to talk about games
yo listen listen listen listen
if it's not a color i don't see you see
the shades on only this is represents
the tcl group you don't talk to okay
okay so okay so
for you mm-hmm i'm gonna give you this
one i'm gonna give you one i'm gonna
give you this one tcl let's go
yeah you just said games
you have not seen that one game running
on your playlist oh shot five
oh shots you have not seen that one game
running on the playstation 5
but what about you have not even seen
the box you have not even seen the box
all we seen was a controller
all we seen was a controller we saw mike
cerny
holding the same controller oh god ball
running on ps5
ratchet and clan come on no no no no no
you saw you saw at the bottom of the
screen it said captured on the
playstation 5.
that's what you
let me tell you all i've seen is cgi
boxes
i don't believe you
they gotta pay it back you know what you
if you i want the same energy
until until they give their boxes up
this whole week
you've been seeing series x's and series
lessons all over
every tech head got him so this
playstation act
so you need to 10 l with them holding it
in their head that's what you do i want
you to i want to no no we've seen that
guy in the factory holding it
i want to see it i want to see it
plugged up to the tv
and i want to see the disc go
what's what's uglier to you and i know i
have a bias but
this answer i can't i can't deny this
what's uglier an xbox series
s with that black circle speaker on it
or a ps5 lane on its side
oh my gosh and you know i'm getting a
ps5 day one but
that thing laying on its side it looks
like have you ever seen that commercial
at the store with the guy who sells the
pillows with the ugly mustache
he looks like that guy actually i'm
going to make a meme today of that guy
holding pillow.com and it's going to be
the ps5
i actually think the playstation 5 looks
better
and then i actually believe so that's
just my i always thought they made
beautiful looking systems my beauty
doesn't
make games like beauty isn't the 12
teraflops
you're eight and you know you're
overclocked you're boosting it's gonna
catch fire
but oh my god i'm just saying this
there's a reason why
they didn't give it to digital foundry
there's a reason why austin evans did
get one
there's a reason why unboxed therapy
didn't get one there's a reason why
that box has not been in nobody's hands
that can actually tell you what the hell
is going on
there's a reason why you have not got
over the shoulder information going on
there's a reason why they're hiding
things with trains coming through and
those are loading screens the reason why
they're pulling forward and you're
talking about i've seen the best thing
ever
you have not seen anything you've seen
games running off for dev kits
so now you're asking me where's the xbox
games at
after this week when that xbox show
comes up
after this week after this playstation
show then the xbox show is going to come
up
then ask me then where the game's at
because that's when you're going to see
the games but when companies are telling
you
oh i remember i remembered assassin
creed you were talking mad crap about
assassin's creed
but it's 4k 60 and it's been being
confirmed have y'all been confirmed
wow listen i hear what you're going
there there's some truth in some of the
stuff you're saying you're going all the
way
you're going all the way uh i will say
this you know
we to your to your point what you're
saying is
you they think you think uh xbox got
more in the chamber once they even
announce on wednesday they dude they got
a show
they told me everything they told you
listen they told you
price they told you uh a release date
they told they showed you the s
they told you when you could pre-order
what else they got to tell you
what they coming around the corner to
bust you upside the head
so i'll get this in the chat then i'll
go ahead and we will move on this is out
of control today
uh let me go back into my thing
oh my god this was this is vintage cake
today all right
we have one we get to the point already
with the five dollars
watch tony come on next week with
another ps5 the master series s
ps5 tcl edition y'all ain't ready for it
they already got it it's called the pc
playstation 5.
there we have the scum cast
chat team xbox baby all day air day
what's good boys absolutely absolutely
then we have pixel bit g with the two
dollar super chat uh who did that for
you can i get an i'm amen from the lord
yeah he was preaching bro i had to book
out the scripture out it was it was
going okay
then we have scrub nurse with the five
dollar switch all right members
turn to your boo turn your book to list
sp to the list spencer chapter three
king coming in absolutely
then we have six player with two dollar
super chat you laugh but king speaks
facts
you know the kid got his followers man
he's in there he's sitting there all
right
a second a big god that was from my list
that was scrub what was the last one you
read scrub that was six slide that was
the last one right now yeah you're good
then we we gotta get we gotta catch up
with us
and then we should be good five dollars
to chat from restored hades i just
wanted to ask the panel do you think
that xbox will put xbox series x in the
design
lab imagine being able to make a custom
controller
that's crazy that's great let me get
jonathan b
i'm convinced mario put the hat on okay
yo yo yo y'all
oh hell no
no savage shout out to east texas alex
with chad randolph inside of luck man
lot of stuff not true
i'll make this quick cause we went over
this one this one a little more um look
it looked like a boom box but
i thought it was phenomenal i thought
the um announcement was great
you know tremendous value tremendous
value
and then the size of it colt right like
so small
sleek you know what i'm saying now i
would have liked you know the color
scheme of
the speaker to be a little different you
know what i'm saying but look at the end
of the day i think it's going to fly off
the shelf i think it represents that
consumer
that like i said is either curious about
the xbox ecosystem
and like like king said i mean they're
going to be
it's a combination it's going to be from
the economical standpoint of the
cheapest being there
and then being able to get into the
ecosystem with a person who may just
only blew the maddens the 2ks you know
i'm saying the call we're going to get
into ea in a minute
but um at the end of the day i think
what's
super underrated is the all-access
program like
they are going all the way in
as far as helping you leave with this
machine
at all costs like they are making the
ease of entry
just ridiculous so i think that's cool i
think um
i do agree i do agree with rand i i i
just
don't think sony's gonna match the 300
price point of the series s i think
that that is just so low tremendous
value and i think to be honest i think
that's the de facto
console that that uh microsoft's gonna
push you know i'm saying i think the x
is more of the enthusiast
you understand more of the hardcore
right core and um you know for guys like
us and stuff like that shout out to us
with the oleds and all that good stuff
and um yeah i'm part of the club i gotta
be fuji
um yeah i think at the end of the day
that you couple
all this with game pass and i predicted
this on unlocked ran i've
i was i got my sasha diamond song for
one i said look when the halo
announcement happened
i said at the end of the day they've got
to push
that they are the utmost value that that
value you come in there you trade on 300
you know you get this game pass you get
all these games
you know what i'm saying and it's it's
it's really i think this is really the
play
i think this is really the play i think
this is what they're trying to do i'm
super excited you know what i'm saying
that the s is able to hit those targets
and like we said i mean is it going to
hit 1440p all the time is it going to
hit
120 hertz all the time no but the fact
that you're getting that
type of package and value that tech and
then remember the cpus are the same
right the nvme they got the ssd that's
the same you know what i'm saying
now i know there's you know conjecture
about the memory and all that other
stuff but at the end of the day
to jump into an ecosystem at 300
with that level of power and
functionality is tremendous
so i think it was a great you know great
move i can't wait to see
you know what else i'll stay marketed
and if they continue to be aggressive
with it but i want to just transition
this into
the leaks and we're going to jump in
unless we got somebody else i'll be we
caught up
i don't know all right cool so look
let's transition right into it look man
this was alex topic i mean attic boobs
were going on a phone about this back
and forth
and the discussion is you know did this
help or hurt
xbox right so i just want to bring some
to your attention i want to shout out
she's from the uh microsoft team
cindy walker she got like this great
australia i don't know if you guys see
it
so pretty much what she said is um when
we refer to leaks she said this week
what we are referring to
is theft she said a leak indicates
someone on the insider gave an outsider
information
she said that sucks but this is not what
happened here and she said dozens of
people poured hundreds of hours into the
messages the assets the storytelling
and it was very exhausting and then he
said she said she continues on to say
that her work
her time and all that was stolen imagine
working on an intricate painting with a
team
of people only to have it taken chopped
into pieces
and presented for someone else's gain
it's simply
not cool now she goes on to say i
appreciate that everyone loves an inside
scoop
and i don't begrudge our press or fans
engaging here she just said i only ask
that next time you see leak
you spend a moment to appreciate that
the work news and product
you know someone art in time and to be
treated fairly so look this was a big
thing you know
obviously you know it came out early you
know obviously we know brad had put some
stuff out as well
and then from there it started to
snowball and then the information came
out
shout out to microsoft for being agile
in the fly
being able to control this and then
still get the message out but i want to
get this to rand first
you know with this leak being out
do you think ultimately this helped
xbox or it hurt xbox with their plans
i mean i guess it really depends i don't
really think it
hurt um i i think it helped in the way
they react so quickly uh they kind of
leaned into the meme
was that like little puppet that looking
sideways and um
you know they just gave everybody all
the information in the videos and
there was uh there was a nice like swell
of uh positivity surrounding xbox for a
couple days until like
until everybody's like oh sirius s is
gonna hold back the gym
oh my god i can't run the you know the
the one that's backpacking
people going to be so confused when they
you know like until that stuff happened
but
uh the leak uh i mean she is right it
was stolen
i mean it was stolen literally off their
server like
the the the marketing materials and the
videos
and then um was given some of it was
given to brad
and brad decided to you know essentially
show the stuff and at that point
microsoft was like oh
you know like we are like yeah they got
everything because
there was supposed to be a behind closed
doors event this week for
press and influencers um
and next week on
on the 17th microsoft was supposed to
announce everything yes that's what
facebook and
so it's like next week we would have
gotten the playstation 5 stuff
and when you say could it have hurt or
help
yeah there's the possibility that
the price like if this was kept secret
and sony didn't know the final price
points although they probably could
guess
that if sony went on wednesday if if
they still
like stuck to their schedule and
announced what their price points were
then
the next day microsoft revealed
everything maybe the playstation would
be
at a different price point maybe a
higher price point maybe not
um i guess that's one of the things
we'll never know yeah but
i don't think that really necessarily
matters in the long run
uh these these were gonna be the prices
xbox was gonna launch at
regardless it was going to be 4.99 and
299.
um and i don't really think that changes
playstations plans too much
maybe they shift at 50 either way make
maybe it was going to be 499 and 550
right
and maybe now it's 450 and 499 right
i mean who really knows um but i mean
kudos to the xbox marketing team for
taking that
like for having your work essentially
taken and they really like
quickly they must have had a
brainstorming session
like what do we do i would imagine
there's people like stick to the plan
imagine people like no we need to get
ahead of this and we need to like regain
the uh you know the uh the story and
then i wonder whose
final call was it to essentially
announce it did someone have to call up
phil and be like
do we go and feels like you know launch
it you know you know hit the launch code
and
deploy everything i would really love to
hear the behind the scenes
absolutely of those decisions that were
being made
yeah um i would i i really do would
love to know who was the final the the
final say on all that
was it the head of marketing or or
whatever but
i mean we know all the information now i
mean that's that's all that really
matters
uh to us i just yeah part of me does
feel pretty
uh you know uh sad for the the people at
the xbox marketing that they didn't get
to
reveal it in the way that they wanted to
even though we all knew
lockhart was real even though there were
some people that were we're sure
lockhart didn't exist people didn't
exist
and now you're going to be able to play
fable on your lockhart
like there were there was a group of
people out there that were that were so
sure that that these things weren't real
and that we were drawing lines into the
sand like you're either with coltrand or
dealer or you're against them
like a lot of smoke man i give you
credit you guys put yourself out there
you got a lot of smoke
let me get cody man like now that we've
got the news you know it's out there you
know you see the marketing team's
comment
and then obviously to rand's point
you've seen also
positive reception right you know for
the most part for the week you know
what's your feeling on this after
reading stuff like that like do you
think
ultimately this still helped xbox or it
could
end up hurting xbox uh i mean it hurts
them
i don't think that they were as agile to
change the price based on what
playstation was going to do
but i did hear for a long time that they
were going to hold out until
sony announced the uh ps5 price
and um that doesn't mean that they were
going to move 50 i think if anybody was
going to move 50
maybe it was playstation sitting and
waiting to see what they can do if
they're going to take a big
loss or try and break even depending on
where xbox sits but
um it is really bad when as someone who
creates things like my whole life i've
created
graphics illustrations and videos and
music
and and to spend hours and hours to have
somebody just take it and just
uh kind of treat it as their own and
people
um like
rand and i and and all other content
creators we got to jump on this news
before the media got it
i mean they kind of got at the same time
as us which doesn't happen often
and um yeah it's really tough
yeah i work i sort of work i've worked
in marketing
uh totally outside of gaming and i
understand
how horrible that is and it it happens
and leaks are becoming more
normal than ever before and it's just
going to make it really
difficult next that means next year or
the next big event
for xbox uh you know rand and i may not
hear whispers and ideas and rumors
um before things and and that's okay
because these things are important
right for them to be able to control
uh how they tell the story yeah no
absolutely i just want to double back
before i pass it to to solve
this for both of you guys like when she
uses
the terminology theft
do you think legal action may be taken
if they're able to determine said
thievery
like what do you guys think about that i
mean that's a strong connotation y'all
someone someone stole it from their
server that is theft
whether or not they're ever gonna find
the person
i mean i i'm pretty sure they know who
did it i mean i'm pretty sure we all
know who
stole it but whether or not you know
they sue that person
is another story um
yeah i mean i guess this is what i
wonder if microsoft made a mistake and
uploaded it to
an unsecure server and that's how you
know that person got it
right um we'll probably never find out
but yeah i mean this was a this was a
serious
serious thing um it is i mean
it is kind of like everybody knew the
console was real
like i mean they they had like the
inserts on the controllers
ultimate cards that literally said it
was there it was like
clearly this was supposed to be
announced
months ago you know and i don't know
at least i guess to say like me and colt
and and dealer you know the
we we've never how do i randall insider
red ellis how to talk let's go oh no i
mean let's get it there's there's this
scenes
there's people that came out after was
announced and said they knew it was real
forever
but like for the months leading up to it
they were
you know sure that it didn't exist and
it was a fairy tale yeah
yeah no um yeah i don't know what to say
about that but
some people know more than other people
some people some people just play
play pat pretend
whatever no no shout out to slow right
quick let me just get a real quick
oh we got somebody enjoying the realm
too slow mo find out super chat high
sets would like to the ilp to know
that the new vto now trade them in to
tsc sales with go
and go with the brand that no longer on
clearance for black friday damn
and then we gotta welcome domino d
get your chat the horns in the chat
domino d welcome to the realm brother
salute put the horns up
it's a great time for you guys to join
the realm of some really good stuff
see mary says they were dropping small
leaks for months i do not believe
someone sold a damn thing for microsoft
that was a controlled leak i 100
guarantee you
it was not a controlled leak i talked to
quite a many people at xbox about it and
trust me
i know a lot of people when the stuff
like this happens that i was like
microsoft did this on purpose it was
totally it was a controlled leak 100
was not a controlled leak trust me on
this one
yes that's the language up here so have
you said something what's up
no no before i go let's get these uh
yeah these two other super chats uh
perfect show
the five dollar super chat shout out to
lourdes colton rand
xbox corner the marketplace will not
dominate next gen everybody be nice to
that
be nice to that like button that's a
little bit hit that like y'all 4 38.
and we have clutch man with the two or
three dollar super chat watching late
and just because
time time i like that we haven't done it
in a minute yeah salute
record yeah we're caught up all right
man what's up let's get to it man good
or
bad this information coming out the way
it came out the information generally
coming out i guess it's good um
but again i got it it sucks for that
team
it really works for that team but
yesterday i sat down and and i watched
the uh the actual presentation that also
leaked
absolutely that sucks um and to see the
amount of work and effort they put into
this to
actually be in a studio and record this
you know knowing the the challenges that
we have with the pandemic and everything
to get all these people in the studio
and i imagined you know for weeks before
that they had to sort of isolate
themselves to make sure they weren't
coming into an environment where they
could make each other sick things like
that
the logistics behind getting people in a
studio to record something like this
has to be crazy and to see it leak out
there before they're ready to do it
just sucks man just sucks um
in terms of how that relates to what
playstation was is going to do
yeah um i kind of agree with cole i
think if there's anybody who was going
to pivot
to microsoft by by having the two
consoles at different price points it
allowed them to
to stand there on their square and once
they decided something stay there
um whereas playstation i think their
willingness to pivot
just to just to just a sort of
pettiness sort of outside microsoft in
the moment even though they can't ever
hit that 300
price point but like i said like there's
probably a section of gamer that
uh that 100 if they're able to get that
digital down to 400
i don't know that that matters that that
100 difference between that and the
series s
means that much to that particular gamer
um
so uh you know we'll see what happens
wednesday but i think it
sucks that they weren't able to do it
the way they wanted to do it yeah um
and it would have been interesting to
see the dynamic um yeah
of of of that being a reaction to the
place
of yeah i was curious we don't we'll
never ever get to see that
um yeah but it's it's gonna be
interesting it's gonna be interesting to
see what happens because
like somebody said in the super chat i
don't think
i i don't think sony dominates the way
that they have is particularly this this
generation specifically because
in the last gen the s series came out as
a as a budget option to try to bring in
the casuals
and to people who may have kind of not
been happy with xbox at the start of the
generation to sort of
say hey this is the reboot and we have
this x coming as well
so it was it was trying to bring people
in after an initial
bad narrative right right we don't have
that going into this generation this
generation they're going in with a
positive narrative
obviously they don't have the amount of
games that they really want there from
their first party
but beyond that the narrative is
positive right so
it's one of those things where the s is
going to be very powerful for them
at launch i believe and and and it's
going to come down to
what's available yeah if any rumors
about playstation to be believed
they ain't going to be a lot of
playstations like that yeah we gonna say
we gonna see man let's get it what's up
murray says uh in chat presentation was
boring as hell i'm glad it leaked
uh you were never supposed to see that
that wasn't that wasn't that wasn't for
for you guys that was
literally for press and influencers to
go along with the
information they would get and that's
why it was filmed in the way it was
filmed like
and and the uh jason ronald uh
featurette was
what we were supposed to see and that
was really phenomenal
gameplay jason broke down attack and
explained where the series s sits and
why
uh somebody in the chat said the series
s is just
the upgrade to the xbox one s that's all
there is to it like
uh yeah we established that like uh at
the beginning of the show there's an s
model which is the base
there's an x model which is the high-end
model
and they just yeah yeah and someone goes
you'd be
someone said in the chat like you'd be
an idiot to buy the
series s after buying the xbox one x i'm
like no
no if you bought an xbox one x last year
for three hundred dollars
you thought oh i'm gonna buy the new one
for three hundred dollars
uh the series s like you're gonna get a
better experience you're getting
way more games that are not in that 30
fps mode anymore
plus you'll get ray tracing you'll get
faster load times velocity architecture
quick resume blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah
blah the one thing i will say uh i know
king uh was talking about an xbox show
after a playstation show or whatever
uh oh i don't think that's happening bro
do you think they're gonna stop it dig
in
i don't i don't think there's anything i
don't think there's an xbox event the
rest of the year
brandon i decided
well i mean we talked about that xbox is
going to do something to showcase
what initiative is working on i think we
haven't heard about
i think the initiative game shows up at
the vgas
oh that makes sense because i mean like
you don't think that xbox is going to do
in
exo 20 well i mean i think king
king meant like another event before no
no no no that's all
i meant more information i meant oh well
i mean more information i might always
call it come out but
i don't think it'll be a showcase like a
40-minute showcase like playstation
how can i explain it uh-oh insider
no no i don't pay attention to those
dudes in my dms
not at all i already look foolish one
time saying something stupid
um never again so how can i explain it
like this show that's coming up this
week
yeah nobody leaked uh sony show
right right so what sony is doing is
they're doing it on their terms
right they're getting a chance to play
ball how they want to play ball
right microsoft was forced to uh
play ball and recover right see
the reason why people think it is a
control leak like myself
was the way they recovered
you know it it gave an air of oh man
you know we're known for messing up look
we had a leak you
look and then you know they came out and
they definitely recovered
i mean they are highly paid
professionals this is their job right
yeah
but at the same time um they have uh
situations that happened before they
didn't recover so well
yeah yeah that's true you know so this
time to see
this it's growing pains in different
areas
but they're learning from mistakes
and they seem to correct those mistakes
going forward
now i think more than anything
being that playstation has their this is
their shot right
coming up this week right um
we we know what phil's made of
we know what phil dominus maximus
aurelius is made of yes what happens
you you you say it's you get those names
from achievements we don't know what gym
dance moves ryan is made of
and i'ma tell you right now
is he is is is he going to be fred
astaire this week
oh we're going to learn what you said
we're going to learn okay
okay what type of captain
they have over there on that ship
because
i'm not going to lie the past bosses
over there
was about that life is this
dude about that life
or he gonna gregory heinz you all night
not sure
you're not sure i i i i don't like his
moves
like i don't like the move that he do
and what i've been seeing is i know phil
about that life
i know he's about that life and answers
about a lot of things though
this is the problem that i have
with playstation guys not giving it up
all right let's go
y'all saw that leak you saw all this
stuff you saw the switch around and i'm
going to give my man the credit
for the turnaround because anytime
there's a failure
you give it to him so you're going to
give him the credit
the same way you give him the failures i
feel that
my man ain't going to be the quarterback
and the team lose
and y'all blame him and when he win
you blame the running blast
don't get that i feel that you're part
of the team
but he the head though i fear that all
right so we coming down to the stretch
this is the stretch guys this is it
this is what we've been talking about
all that pandemic stuff and all that
other stuff
this is where we finding out what pegs
is coming forward
i want to know what this is about i'll
feel that part
because i i look phil in his eyes mm-hmm
oh boy lie to me yet i'll feel it
i feel listen i mean at the end of the
day yeah we got we're going to learn you
know i'm saying we're going to figure
out
we're at the moment the chicken games
are over
the high stakes poker all that good
stuff look i'll just get into it real
quick i'll make my point quick one more
sovereign said one thing yeah okay
sovereign said
they could pivot yes
this is the same boss that told you back
at pat wasn't a thing
i want you to remember who he is i want
you to remember his dna
this is the same boss that walked out on
that stage and gave you a logo and said
thank you good night
yo you stupid
[Laughter]
he that dude this is the same dude that
thought mark cerny talking was a good
idea
i want you to know who you are dealing
with because this ain't the same sony
brothers y'all
y'all been talking about past and all
the stuff that you have done
those were other dudes who cannot be
found
where is sean layton yeah
he can't talk they got him silence so
i'm um this is telling like sovereign
said
this week do they pivot right do they
come in with the 50
off like ah like are they about that
life or do they sit there and say we're
the market leader
you gonna follow us regardless now if
they if they stand on a square
and they don't respect your dollar and
they're coming to the party
with a weaker system that costs more
oh you gonna still stand on that square
and support them and don't tell me it's
about them games
because those games ain't that day one
bro so tell me
is god awoke only worth your money
damn okay are you here for the hope
while i'm sitting there playing hundreds
of games in 4k
120 frames per second and i'm laughing
at you
are you really going to stand on that
square
oh you're just going to come over to
this side with the air smell
just a little bit better because we
under a different type of leadership are
you gonna stand with a real dude
um or the tap dance dude we gonna find
out if he got on his head
what's the cap dance thing the damn
dance beast that like sony
i mean he created kid created this
narrative of jim dan's move ryan
and it started because the the pivoting
so basically when
okay all right remember when like they
were like hey you know we're never gonna
put our games
you know on pc you know remember things
started to change it's up to more lines
when microsoft strategies so according
to king
he feels that jim is compliant he's
compliant with phil dominus's moves
and he's complicit and he's getting the
playstation nation on board
and the same thing with the cloud
infrastructure so king has
king's belief is that sony is not the
same sony
and that he's dance moving because he's
not sticking to the things that they
used to do under the prior regime
which is exclusives only you know we
don't believe in that you know backpack
stuff and now
so that that's where this is going you
know kind of thing so that that's where
it comes from coach just to okay
yeah but look let me get it i know we
got to switch back to get my balls off
real quick look at the end of the day
yes i am upset i'm sad for the team that
it did get out in that way
but i'm gonna say something
controversial rant
i'm gonna say it is good for xbox that
it happened
and the reason why is i feel
and let's be honest when craig hit them
streets
it was a low point i know
you want to know how low it was you were
in my dms being like
talk to me talk to me i did counseling
you were you were you were you were you
you even threw some of your podcast
mates under the bus
you're like bro
hard man saab's flipping on me and i'm
like
dude so i've had bars but it was
scathing
it was scathing bars off and and at the
end of the day
all i could say is this like what to
king's point
i judge a dude i don't just do when
things are going well i'm gonna look at
you
when you're at your lowest and we all
know halo they had all their eggs in
that basket
whether it was right or wrong all the
eggs was in the
eggs broke and it came out on screen it
was
all over the screen as king says right
and
no one you know don't get me wrong i did
thought the gameplay looked good i'm a
halo
or combat evolved dude so i'm biased i
like that retro look
that's me so i was happy but i could
understand the master saying
fam that don't look next-gen you can't
talk about 120 hertz and power in this
and then your game looking like that so
at that point it was the
utmost low it felt like shades
of 2013 you know shades
so for me this leak i got to be real
cold like
it was the most positive
energy i've seen from the xbox community
for a span of two to three days
and i'm just gonna leave my other point
in with the ea because this is a
combination thing we need to go deep
with the ea thing
but at the end of the day you had bam
series s
oh my god they really did hit 300. okay
it looks like a boombox but 300
wow like you getting all that power
you're getting all like oh wow series x
is 500.
they're not going six sorry forte sorry
i got no six what's your thing
corte's in the chat now yeah well he
said he's gonna he's on his way to do
another podcast
at the end of the day you know you had
to it was like bam
bam okay cool right then
like ran says you get all a third party
to now pivot
their release dates to november 10th so
i'm like
fire assassin's creed 60 frames per
second we finally get that out boom
gears tactics
okay boom then you get okay
ea right and i remember ran remember you
was talking me off the ledge with
certain things right
and i said i got to judge him he has to
i said phil had to do two things for me
i told you they were the ea thing was
happening you did you did weeks ago you
definitely did
my whole thing was you had to do two
things to to help
get the confidence of the base up which
was one you got to do a short-term move
and you got to do a long-term move
short-term move being something in game
pass that's around launch to get people
excited now i know people don't go crazy
for ea to hardcore but you got to
understand there's a subset of gaming
there's a strong amount
that they're going to see these games
whether it's fight for madden
all this stuff inside that package right
of game pass ultimate and that is going
to appeal to them
and we have to stop thinking of us just
as the hardcore game and we represent
everybody
we don't like king said there's going to
be that mom there's going to be that
parent there's going to be that person
that's like yo i only got 300 or hey
you telling me i can pay 25 and i can
get in right now
and i can play nba 2 or whatever it is
right
there are more of them than there are us
we influence but there are more of them
and that's the thing people got to
understand so to me you know i'm saying
you know i hope they forgive brad but
at the end of the day i have never seen
that amount of positive xbox news
back to back to back even critically
acclaimed i'm
seeing playstation influencers big media
guys say oh
for that 299 i'm 1440p 120
i'm in fam you know i'm seeing people
who don't
even care about the expo shout out to
jeff shout out to whis no central he's
he got a good tweet he was like
yo i'm seeing a lot of my guys all of a
sudden care about the xbox
king is right price made a
huge difference last gen we could sit
there and save messaging we could sit
there and say we trade games all that
did happen it wasn't yeah it wasn't
games
they didn't come for the first year you
had facts colt
you had a a powerful system you know a
more powerful playstation 4
for less money than the xbox one it was
a new bread and now it kind of feels
like it's
this so to me i think it was great
i think i think phil did a fantastic job
you know as far as you know
the whole messaging i'm sticking to that
i'm sad it did leak you know what i'm
saying
but i do feel the ea stuff all the
series of announcements ran
i just felt was like a shot like it was
like euphoria industries remember like
the zion scene in the matrix all the
xbox fans
like everybody was like remember the
dance scene
it was it was i've never seen that
before bro like it was
crazy this week it was so positive
just to see boom boom boom and then like
like coke said jason ronald comes out
and was like
just just perfectly explaining the
message the goal look you don't care
about 4k because let's be real
king we joke about tcl last point
but there's so many guys that don't care
about 4k
that don't get it we got we even did a
pc survey right it was a pc server it
was like 65 percent
they not even you know what i'm saying
using this so it's like
we got to be real with how much the
casual
dominates the market and has an
influence on things we got to be real
that's
that's my final point and i just thought
it was i thought it was a fantastic week
and you know we're gonna see but that's
all i got cuss off get the super chat
chat up and then we finish with the last
topic uh
sure let me see one second okay so we
start off with element appeal
with the five dollar super chat digital
foundry had a pre-taped video about the
series that's
they definitely knew yeah they they knew
about it when it went to cdx
they got show they've known for quite
some time about it
um we have gaming forte with the five
dollar super chat
sucks for people that poured hours into
their message that's many xbox fans
happy about the news
everyone else's opinions can kick rocks
then we have neo mental with the 20
super chat sony 100 has to match the
series s
the series s's price point look at
everything microsoft has done with the
payment plan and getting users into
their ecosystem
install base is more important to yeah
once again it's more important
uh than losing money on a console so
when he can't lose the way microsoft
can yeah that makes a lot of sense a lot
of sales i don't know about
matching that 300 dollar price point
king calling out sony's dancing white
knights
there we have iron mike with the 5 super
chat we're going to talk about this brad
sam's tweet
playstation you're going to announce
availability hey
yo brad no i'm trying to defend you bro
but you out here
thugging like you thugging like you got
you bout to release someone
like yeah so there we have
a stitch with the five dollar super chat
question how likely is sony to charge
for the new version of
the last of us two and ghosts for the
ps5
of course yeah okay so if y'all thought
nintendo got you
check it out when that i say
in january you're gonna get the last of
us hardcore hd edition
16 frames a second with ghost of shashi
we're right around the corner with the
same thing
oh back-to-back oh man you're gonna have
games in january baby savage
savage
um we have e murray with the five
dollars in the chat look these fools out
here talking about craig with buck
snacks on ps5 as a large game
wow and we have tony bryant with the
five dollar super chat
insider and equals play off lebron
inside of red come through i'll slide it
at the end
drunken ninja with the five dollar super
chat so when are we adding the series s
to that giveaway
when one get one free laughing don't be
trying to juice the giveaway
to get asked
[Music]
um let me see hold on a second so i have
to go back okay when we have eagles fan
76 with a five dollar super chat
when do you guys think the national
commercials start for xbox and what is
the message that you sell to the masses
let's go um when does a commercial start
when's the release what's the rollout
rand i have no clue
no clue one i mean we'll we'll find out
eventually
when your video goes up that's what
we'll find out yeah you know what the
other thing i wanted to mention
i totally forgot let's go um i know some
some playstation
nation are in the chat like jay barry
and christopher hart and stuff
do you guys listen to your playstation
insiders because they always wrong
like weren't we supposed to be
pre-ordering the like wasn't i supposed
to be able to pre-order the ps5 on on
on the ninth yeah ran wasn't the uh ps5
supposed to be 13 points it was like 13.
it wasn't
they they did remember when they signed
that um fight club waiver
on um on the playstation so they can get
uh
the chance to get the playstation five
that fight club waiver
talking about the pre-order you all
i was up early on on september 9th i was
like all the insiders were like 25th
anniversary
of the playstation one pre-order
starting today i'm like all right i'm
ready and then at eight o'clock in the
morning
phil spencer's like uh uh 400 series act
ea playing game pass xbox all access
i was like okay so sony's gonna announce
the price soon i mean surely the
insiders can't be completely wrong all
the time
and they were wrong again surprise
surprise look code red got that light
to take your [ __ ] to say the devil i
don't get involved with it but
i mean who else to say it but the real
insider
randy spider wow
you know what back i'll tell you guys
i'll be real with you guys um
rand called me like two years ago and
he's like hey you know how i'm an
insider i'm like yeah ran
everybody knows it he goes xbox has two
consoles
i will i will i will say though sony
sony seems to keep uh
they yeah they have a tight shot they're
going to try
to give it to them things don't leak
that's why i always laugh with certain
people tweet certain stupid
all the time and they're consistently
proven wrong
time after time after time yep yeah what
has leaked on the playstation of the ps5
like it they have been
really clean like miles morales i
i was like whoa miles morales like i
mean i guess you could see it coming
uh the way that the game ended
phenomenal game one of my favorites this
generation
but like we just there it was when it
was announced i'm like oh that is so
cool
and then fable i was like it took the
wind out of myself two years i was like
oh they finally show here there you go
working on that right oh yeah i mean
it's
crazy facts man let's move on man follow
your transition perfectly caught you
know and um let's get these super chat
before we get a switch first yeah then
we will transition
completely we have bounty boom with the
10 super chat i think xbox is going to
have a different perspective when it
comes to downloading games
because if you have game pass and an nx
cloud it might say it's already
downloaded just play
let's go then we have the medic
with the two dollars
salute what the hell is a denmak
i don't know you got uh ravenflow oh
that's that's from the cumulative that's
what the kubrick say what the hell
did mack the raven flow with the final
super chat
uh you know sony and nintendo's
marketing isn't as open as microsoft ran
they just show you the games i don't
know about insiders
yo let me get a rod of this wow let's do
that
sony don't leak except user data wow
wow that was messy
i was blessing
that was pretty good that was pretty
good i guess i guess i haven't been
following colt's advice of being nice
this podcast
clearly oh my gosh you gotta have that
four factor authorization on
four factors you get a letter in the
mail
that's like giggles please sign here sir
that was good your salute man we gotta
move on final topic
obviously this is you um you you have
concerns you know we have a showcase
going on but you you've got some
concerns i
want to talk about reference to ps5
what's going on man
well initially it was um you know
microsoft came and punched him in the
mouth and i'm like
all right this is your week 25th
anniversary come on guys
you know and like ryan said a lot dudes
in my damn yo this is it you can
catch it this week the fade is coming to
faith
you have to run the fade on the
anniversary king they was looking for
you
and i'm sitting there like okay i'm
sitting outside on my porch with the
baseball bat
and um lo and behold phil pull up who
got who you got beef with who
yeah let me put this out for you thanks
phil
so so okay so now now that that happened
now that we understood that they were
scared to come outside on a birthday
um why you gotta say it like that
they don't want to go to the store to
get the milk they don't want their
breakfast
yeah the birthday parties like nah
that's 25 joints i'm not trying to catch
them
but um we have this uh is it wednesday
or thursday that we got to do this live
show wednesday we got to do logic can i
can let me preface it real quick yes um
yeah they finally came out the tweet
they said the uh playstation launches
holiday
it's called the showcase joining us
september 16th 1pm
pacific the next digital showcase will
weigh in about 40 minutes and future
updates on the latest titles from
sony's worldwide studios and world-class
development
partners yeah so um
my thing is uh what do we expect to get
from this show
uh on wednesday uh do we
do we get priced uh do we get a release
date
do we get um pre-orders uh do we get the
whole kitten caboodle
or do they get a launch uh selection
what are y'all looking forward uh on two
on wednesday
uh coming from sony camp since they've
been so tight-lit then they haven't had
any leaks no doubt let's get
colt eastwood which got mad i want to
see miles morales gameplay because we
haven't seen
a second of that yet thank you i can't
wait for that one
um what else do i need to see from them
i hear there's gonna be a jaw-dropping
announcement
for the playstation event so i don't
know what that could be
maybe they're gonna announce psvr too
interesting i don't care about that
i mean either okay i mean it is weird
that they haven't really talked
very much about pspr but i mean that
does speak to
the attachment in the market like vr is
not very big
psvr that that'll be announcement for
next year
okay and that's not that's not an
announcement for launch gotcha
so yeah i mean i kina bridge of spirits
got delayed i was really looking forward
to that game it just looks
really satisfying to play it looks
really cool so i just want to remind
people that
what's going on in the world is not just
happening to xbox
it's happening to multiple developers
it's happening to
first party developers and um it sucks
and i i think we're gonna see it pour
into next year as well
like some of the tv shows like those of
you waiting for the next season of
um the umbrella academy and stranger
things and all these big shows
like if we're expecting those to jump in
in june or july
stuff is going to get moved facts
because these people can't get together
with their people
and their teams and their equipment and
studios and
it's really going to be rough and
there's going to be a good flow of games
from some of these studios around the
launch area the consoles and then i
think
in the spring and summer we might see a
lull and maybe next
holiday i don't i hope everything goes
well yeah no you made a good point code
because people don't realize like you
said
mo cap think about how that's affected
you know um
even uh games as far as orchestras music
coming anything that involves coming
together physically being in a
studio you know which is most everything
which is most everything so this is
really going to affect like you said
perfect analogy with the movie industry
you know the marvel cinematic universe
all that that stuff is affected
you know so much is affected right now
so again like you said great point it's
not just
xbox sony as well and i i think you're
nailing it with as far as
you know obviously you said with the
keynote delay and stuff like that you
know
i think a lot of it i think ryan said it
too which is you know they've got to
wait to see what's actually available
right you know what and i think maybe
that could be a lot of the holdout
process but yeah fantastic point scott
i do agree lord rand what
are you looking forward to what you
think's going down with the playstation
um you know i'll probably have a video
out about this maybe tomorrow
mm-hmm my predictions with a fire
thumbnail from coach
with the fire graphic
in a world where colt makes all the fire
thumbnails
stealing and everybody's stealing i mean
do you see the one he made the other day
with like this with the
assassin's creed character oh my lord
fire
um so okay
i think we get a tour of the user
interface
um because they teased it in the last
one and i do think they'll kind of
go a little bit into it more in this one
and i think it would be really cool if
like maybe the show
uh started up in the user interface and
then like
you just kind of like clicked on like a
game and it just kind of
showed you how fast it could get into
the game like spider-man miles morales
you see it in
uh you know the ui and you click on it
and
boom the gameplay demo whatever is right
and i would imagine we would get a lot
of gameplay
for stuff um
most people are expecting release date
which i think will be
november 17th i think it'll be the week
after xbox like either the 17th or the
20th i don't expect it to be
after uh i don't expect it to be after
the thanksgiving holiday right um if
if they somehow were i would look at
that a little bit
weird like maybe they were having
production issues because why is it
after that so i'm looking at the 17th
price points like
i think let's go you can make a case for
any of them 399
and you know 449 or 399
and 499 or 449 and 499
and how i think there's even a
possibility it could be 499 and 549.
you could make a case for any one of
those price points
of the two um personally i think it's
probably going to be 449 and 4.99
uh but if sony really wants to go in
uh they'll price it at 399 and 4.99 um
now i if sony does show like a brand new
game from first party
i think it's i think they'll tease god
of war too
oh i think there's a good chance
see i'm not gonna say it's a good chance
because i i just ran down
i think they might they could
essentially end on god or two
um to get people really excited even
though that game's probably not coming
to 2023
but that'll work boy
i do think i do think i do think launch
day
is going to be a little bit weaker than
sony wants like i think demon souls
and destruction all-stars will be there
um i know playroom
is is like in you know like in with
every system
but i have a feeling spider-man is not
going to launch with the system
i have a feeling spider-man's gonna
catch
maybe a two-week delay maybe comes out
in december
okay i don't i don't think it's gonna be
delayed to 2021 but i wouldn't be
surprised if it if like
a couple weeks like it's so important to
if it's so important to have first party
exclusive on the console for launch
like why can't they push i mean hey if
xbox can launch a
system without an exclusive than
playstation can
they don't have game pass
i'm just saying like i think a lot of
the place
i think the reason why sony was
announcing this stuff so late is because
with the way the world is which cole
just mentioned
a lot of studios are scrambling to hit
milestones and deadlines
and i think it's a possibility
that you know he said please throw red
in the bushes
he's not killing you with this spiderman
thing bro he's not
i'm really you i i
look i'm not saying it's happening i'm
just saying i wouldn't be surprised
but then if it does happen just remember
where you heard it
yo he's been known rand has been known
to break these kind of things on iop i'm
just saying no no
i don't know i i i don't know i'm not
gonna put that up
don't be surprised don't just don't be
surprised if if games
shift around i do expect demon souls to
be there at launch and a couple others
but
i mean all they really said about miles
morales was that it was holiday 2020
that game could still come out in
december and
like still be they they wouldn't have
lied and they wouldn't have been delayed
they never gave it they never gave it a
a a release date
they don't do they have any games with a
release date no it was just
no was this like uh golf ball was
holiday 2020
miles yeah i just don't remember seeing
a single playstation 5 next generation
game with an
actual day and date uh
no no no no xbox doesn't xbox
uh didn't i mean did xbox have it xbox
didn't have a date for halo infinite
before it didn't trade
true only so rand's right like they
have been ambiguous for reasons so that
they can be
fluid right because things are really
difficult right
that's the problem like covet is
affecting development of games
so much right and i i
if so sony needs the console out before
thanksgiving
right yeah you need that console out
it's not coming
and if it and if insomniac was like
we're trying our hardest but we won't be
done
until two weeks after sony's not gonna
hold up the launch
for that game they'll just say release
it and just you know in december
i mean i could be wrong and maybe
spider-man and
you know spider-man's launch title and
then i'm sure jay barry will clown me on
twitter
yeah uh which is perfectly fine i mean
because i want it to be a launch game
because i'm getting the ps5 day one like
colt factory
and i'm not really interested in godfall
and like demon souls really isn't my
thing
me neither what spiderman is yeah like i
love
i love the the last spider-man game and
i really want to play this one so i hope
it's there
i'm just i'm just just some things it's
like okay you know what and
don't be surprised that there's also uh
maybe some third-party
time exclusive stuff uh final fantasy
16.
look final fantasy 16 is a time
exclusive hang on one second hey chris
hart buddy let me tell you something
uh you you tell me that you're gonna
call me out like you always do and call
me king
yes i am your king but hey let me tell
you something
i i just finished saying that both xbox
and playstation have the same problem
they have to deal with yes
both of them have to worry about when
they can delay games or if they're gonna
have first first-party content
i believe that spider-man miles morales
is coming out
right at the launch window of the ps5
that i'm getting
and i love that spider-man game so i'm
looking forward to it
so there's just this error of where
people just think
somebody's always on one side or the
other right i
am fully acknowledging that xbox is not
launching with halo infinite and that's
their problem they have to deal with
but both consoles have not given any
strong dates for their first party games
yeah chris why are you going to read a
logical one
yeah what's that why you got to be the
logical one why are you you better be
the last i don't know
some people are more interested in
dramatization and
calling people out going to conquer war
court and banging the gathering
it's like it's ridiculous that you have
to understand like this
is gaming and the and everything has its
own side
facts yeah and the ravenflow says xbox
won't have a halo infant until next year
wow thanks for the news update they said
themselves 2021 and ravenflow said um
that uh kina bridge of spirits was only
moved to uh
the next quarter like yeah i mean for
all we know halo infinite could come out
in spring 2021
or they do what i think they should do
is wait until next holiday
and make improve that yeah that game
because
halo 4 on master chief collection looks
two or three times
better than halo infinite so i hope 343
is
uh continuing to do what they can do and
make a great looking
halo game and that is better than five
was agreed agree
and i'm done talking no no i see what
you say and i'll give it back to you
ryan i just wanted to say that um
look at the end of the day you know
whether we want to credit
sony's marketing there is a little bit
of end you know ambiguousness
as far as you know dates and stuff like
that and it could very
well be that they want to use it in
conjunction when they actually say
the launch date of the playstation 5.
but we also
in colts defense and reigns defense we
also got to say they have not given
harder fans
dates to say yo it's definitely at
launch it's just say
holiday right or that could mean
anything so we got to play
fair here y'all i see y'all playstation
nation acting like it's
definitely coming there's a chance
that's always saying there is a chain
when you say holiday
you leave the doors wide open so that if
it don't happen on launch you'll be like
yo i said holiday
you know what i said if it do but when
you say launch like the only game i
remember specifically ran
is yakuza remember when yakuza for the
xbox series actually it said launch they
said
launch and then that was the 13th which
is why i thought this
console was going to launch the 13th
right and then they announced that
the system was the 10th and then yakuza
moved its release date from the 13th to
the 10th
exactly um sony sony secured a lot of
time to exclusivity
for a lot of third-party games and a lot
of content like
spider-man for avengers and they'll
probably
like i said final fantasy 16 is a time
i'm
pretty sure is a timed exclusive for for
the playstation 5 and it
might be revealed there the silent hill
game
pretty sure exists although who knows if
it's actually going to be
at the show um
bethesda and sony are pretty chummy i
wouldn't be surprised if starfield's an
exclusive for playstation
um whoa whoa the whole joint
come on rain whoa time coming from the
exclusive
the whole joint i'm just saying i
wouldn't be surprised
that's all wow wait i thought they were
chummy with xbox not knowing what did he
do
and running around running loose out
there yeah
those are games that needed funding and
you know sony reached out and
gave them funding yeah well you guys
don't know listen if you're not gonna
put your passion in projects
the rumors were tony the rumor was sony
went shopping
they went to every publisher to see what
they could get exclusive games or
exclusive characters
yup i did hear that they're saying like
i'm not
my point is if sony has big exclusive
games i'm not gonna be surprised because
i'm expecting a lot i'm expecting that
they
spent a lot of money getting timed
exclusives because one of their goals
one of their goals is to prevent
microsoft microsoft's
whole thing is game pass we've talked
about it consistently right
it's their platform that's what they
want you it's why like you can get uh
the xbox one s for 25 a month and save
60
because they want you in game pass
they're like give you the two years of
game pass
and they'll lose and they'll lose money
on it but that's fine because
you're going to be in game pass for
years to come exactly so part of sony
strategy
is we need to convince people to get
playstation 5 right away to upgrade from
the playstation 4 and you do that with
your own first party exclusives as well
as third party ones
but then also their strategy is to
essentially
stifle microsoft's access to third-party
games to put in the game pass
yes so you basically go around and you
either take things from the game like
avenge like spider-man from avengers
which makes people want to purchase the
game on playstation
or you just outright completely make it
timed exclusive
uh whether it's like the indie titles
like kenya or
you know our favorite bug snacks so
those games are going to be on
playstation for a bit
um and then the bigger ones like you
know like nobody thought death loop
would be an exclusive
i mean final fantasy 6 i get why square
enix would do it
but i'm just saying like i think sony
sony's gonna have a lot of games that
they're gonna have exclusive because
they paid for it
yeah back at the truck up it's just just
to jump i also need that
i need to add i said this right before
we started the show uh
king didn't like it but playstation has
like five or six
pretty dang good games that are not
going to be on xbox in 2021
i think rand and i have kind of counted
them out but i mean that's a pretty
amazing
i'm just adding to what rand said that
playstation has their
third party and first party games coming
next year
and then they went shopping to see if
they can grab some timed exclusive stuff
right uh to to add to that
so yeah it's going to be pretty crazy
the difference in what playstation
has um for the first year alone no i
mean
these are these are fantastic points
before i give it to you so i know we
gotta catch it
um rand's making a good point cause i've
been telling people this
that i think they recognize as far as
from the power differential
right so one thing that i think the xbox
one x did fantastic
was they said here's digital foundry go
ahead right
and digit friday got ahold of stuff and
then when those comparison videos
started coming out and we started seeing
native 4k stuff
and you know the comparisons with their
version being the superior version
you know i think a good counter ran's
making a great point that sony could do
is say look
we will buy either the game exclusive or
content like avengers exclusive
so this can counteract it even if your
game looks better
we've got this coveted content that you
know you might not be able to resist
and have to get it over over here in the
case of like i said spider-man with
avengers and stuff like that
and to me it's more strategy you know
i'm saying i know people a lot of people
don't like it
but at the end of the day i think that's
things that they're gonna have to do
because at the end of the day if it pans
out how it was with the xbox one x and
the series x
versions either start showing superior
frame rates better resolution better
performance
and you know what i can't wait for code
i got to be i got to be out i gotta be
messy for a second technically
investment
oh yeah i want to i can't wait for the
uh
loading time comparison like i don't
know why
i'm being messy with that but i really
want to see like the ssd
of the playstation 5 and see what these
differences are
right so god forbid if there's anything
disparity there you know how twitter's
gonna be right
it's gonna be nuts if one ain't out
performing and loading faster than the
other and everybody's gonna say see
that's the power and ssd
or velocity architecture i actually you
know i actually don't
know for sure from all of the digging
i've done into vc pack and
and and the velocity architecture
the advantage that xbox has on their own
um
i don't know how developers will be able
to utilize that
right for the xbox to their advantage
or i don't know how developers would be
able to advance take the advantage of
the ps5
what if um let's say the next success
sesqui valhalla comes out what if it
loads up faster on the xbox because bc
pack and some other things just happened
to work better or developers were
saying hey this was a lot easier and
it's faster and it loads up in eight you
know six seconds
and on the ps5 it loads up in nine or
ten you never know but
bro the raw numbers say that a ps5 game
should load
load up two times faster than the xbox
um
keep in mind we saw outer worlds loading
in 12 seconds with absolutely no
velocity architecture or any of that
um so i mean and jason
ronald also said that they're able to
get 2.5 times
faster with velocity architecture than
the raw compute numbers say they'll do
and those raw compute numbers say that
it's half of
if you that's i did that video like
three or four months ago i said if you
look at what's going on and the stuff
the additional stuff that xbox is doing
beyond the raw numbers
playstation 5 may not be the fastest
loading console
in in most every game and i'm talking
about multiplats right so it will be
interesting
will it matter absolutely not but
people will like champion anything
listen as tech enthusiasts
there's there's some fun to it and i
would call it load gate
load gate is gonna be lit when these
things start coming out but we get
benchmarks and games and hands and
that's gonna be fun i'm looking forward
for that because i just i just it'll be
nice
it'll be nice when these guys don't have
38 seconds
to pick up their phone on twitter and
clown other people while they're waiting
for a game to load
that'll be nice it sucks it sucks it
sucks from this point that uh
because we can't talk about resolution
right
right we can't talk about frame rate
right so we got to go at something that
we think that they're able to compete in
right
oh like so we're going to go at this ssd
right because they can't compete in
price
now the first time uh xbox had the games
in the beginning right they didn't have
the power of the resolution
and they didn't have the price that's
where they lost so all these people
talking about oh they're gonna have
these games and all these games gonna be
there and all this
games didn't dictate the winner it
didn't dictate it at all
so i don't care how much they went
shopping i don't care what the hell is
in a shopping cart
i don't care
because at the end of the day it's the
guys that's going to purchase the
cheapest console
the consumer is a cheap consumer
he walks into the store and he figures
what's the most he can get for his buck
now it's a it's a a one percent that
goes in there and they don't care
give me that give me the best and don't
look at the price tag
but then there's a consumer that will
read everything down to the bottom line
and
like coach said there's a checklist
right next to the joint
and you say okay this one don't got 4k
and this one
don't got one terabit but that's it yeah
this one's 200 cheaper give me that
that's it
so i i really don't care this week
coming up yo
shout out to daryl j he did your old joy
can i get a lockhart please you did the
old job
it's just i need to say something on
this it does it's just a fact
now they're gonna have these little
exclusive time
stuff that they went nick picking and
trying to put little ornaments on their
christmas party
you want to go get cheap ornaments for
your christmas tree you know that you
you look at the dude tree you like
when you throw away the whole tree with
like ornaments on and everything exactly
that's the tree that goes to the bushes
and you see everything on it you just
threw it outside in the lawn
cover listen okay y'all winning got
spiderman okay okay
revolution though i mean let's let's
i'ma keep it funky y'all dudes is
talking a lot of hot
trash it's time now it's fight time all
right
it's fight time y'all was talking price
before that's done you can't talk that
right
and y'all talking resolution we already
know it's done the fight is over there
so okay so now i hear you're talking
about something they can compete and
they can run around faster
i don't care i'm buying it
i'm purchasing it and and i told y'all
before
spider-man is not day one oh oh you
standing
with you i'm standing on it listen you
know why because i got a picture of his
leg
i'm tired y'all and i predict this week
we're going to see another ratchet in
clank trailer oh my god
they're going to show you the extended
extended clip of the
clip that she saw already the double raw
footage
clip the dude y'all dudes keep falling
for this banana in the tailpipe
and i'm so sick and tired of hearing
everybody making the narrative for this
dude
but when it comes to xbox well you know
this the series x might hold them back
i don't know whatever the way the
scaling goes
you know um i really feel that you know
price wise and it's not a good
comparison no
[ __ ] all languages
i'm so sick and tired of there's always
an excuse
well for these dudes but when microsoft
does it right they got you boxing they
got you squeezed tight
i come out with some ssd talk i'm like
you
seriously gonna do that all right you
can't even buy a gpu for three hundred
dollars that has great tracing
that'll do this 1080p 60 and 120s
like it's hope that velocity
architecture i
hope oh that is smacking it about oh my
god
i if i get that one video i don't care
what game it is
if you get that velocity architecture
loaded faster than the vfo
game you go within one game
we ain't gonna hit the end of it one
game you better load
faster on everything one game
i'm gonna
because i'm telling you right now one
game it flowed in um you gonna see a
video
oh yo attic in the building what's up
adam you said when i missed king you
missed rare form cake salute
oh my god yo king is in his bag all i
will say to king before i give it a song
this is what you catch up let me get out
is that king we do gotta say that brand
recognition
right they they they built such a cachet
with
quality games you know what i'm saying
and they dominated the jet the last gym
we gotta admit that there's going to be
people that still don't
jump ship that there's going to be
people who stay synonymous
with the brand and want to see what they
do now to your point
yeah they price is going to be key you
know what i'm saying we're going to see
how they come in you know what i'm
saying it's going to be
you know legit it's going to be too
overpriced and and we got to see i also
feel like what is actually available
what colt
is saying as well you know is a is a big
thing because
when you're going to the store right you
know what it is spider-man there
is ratchet and clank there we're here in
wrestling clink is launch window
right so i'm assuming that's not there
on day one right
but what else is there to ran's point is
it a demon soul do they have
like that's gonna be key and to your
point king i do understand your
frustration
in a sense of you know they've built up
such a cachet
that it's almost to the point where
people can
buy it on hope of the promise that they
know these god of war two these horizons
zero dawn you know what i'm saying two
is coming so it's just gonna be
interested i i do understand yo
you're going in extra but i do
understand your frustrations it's just a
fact
we're going to see about the ssd we're
going to see because soft get the joint
and then um yeah we got it we got to get
uh red's counterpoint i know you had to
get some stuff and then i'll get off
hold on second let me do this yeah we
got a lot we got a lot pop out east
give me a moment sure no problem no
problem we got a lot shout out to attic
pulling up last
minute 463 to check hit that like y'all
for for real yeah i i i am
really excited to see what sony's uh
show is um
like maybe they keep it look more
low-key
and keep it like oh just extended looks
at the games that are coming launch
launch dates and stuff but i don't know
like i think they do want to like leave
people like with like a huge
announcement which is why like
even though god of war two was far away
yeah i i think there's a maybe a chance
you get like a
maybe a 30-second teaser like just like
just like thor
or something and kratos and like boom
god of war ii and
you know and that would be trolling so
yeah
yeah get them out of there y'all know
what to do mods that would you know
that would go a long way and maybe final
fantasy 16 would be a big thing too
but or maybe maybe king's right maybe
it's more
more like lower key and maybe somebody's
like well do we have to because like
we're gonna sell out everything this
holid like right
like what's the point in like using the
god of war
bullet so soon when everybody's going to
buy the console
you know at launch anyways we'll just
wait till next year so it's going to be
interesting to see
like what they decided to do for that
yeah absolutely
absolutely sorry we're ready for the uh
the chat sir yeah yeah
we're ready okay cedric h with the five
dollar super chat
i told you guys ps got that only fans
you gotta pay for the free oh
yeah and
bounty boom with the five dollar super
chat i thought i read somewhere
where they said it's all about the games
nothing about the console and that's
true oh my god people are going to be
flipping yeah they they
kind of did not indicate they were gonna
get priced
which is crazy which is crazy if that is
the case um
gamer by choice 20 super chat salute to
the realm for the great show and awesome
guests and wonder topics
i hope i can pre-order ps5 on wednesday
and xbox on the 22nd great show
yes thank you sir thank you sir then we
have the raven flow with the two dollar
switch
spider-man and delayed kids move we'll
celebrate yes
bottles for sure then we have near
mental with the five dollar super chat
all that money spent on exclusives and
time content and you really think sony
won't spend some money
discounting a lower level system not all
the way to 299 dollars i won't
yeah maybe 3.99 sure
not all the way down to 299. yeah not
for what's in there not for what's in
there
it's it's basically the same components
as a page just put out there
even if it's true that the ps5 was um
slated for 2019 right i mean they still
had that price
that price target even for a 2019
release
that they have to hold on to even if
they just spent some time
i mean really that just that that
supports that
they put more time and r d into getting
it up to where it is now
which costs more time and money and and
the silicon in there
is still expensive and yeah it's so it's
yeah i don't know i'm i've been hearing
the 399 and for
499 but i mean 3.99 and
i hate saying the 99 and uh 449 you know
400 and 450 i like to say the even
number it's easier
for me to see it but 400 and 450 makes
sense it's just
it's weird to say you stick an a uhd
drive which we know is only a 50
consumer product um after the fact not
like cost or at cost
you know after you get in retail and
everything the difference should be
about 50 bucks
and um so i really think it should be
3.99
and 3 or 449 yeah
but we'll see no gamer by choice the 10
super chat we have time exclusives
prevent digital foundry doing side by
sides at the time of launch this helps
move that conversation until
uh it's an advantage for playstation on
multi-platz great show
cool cool cool thank you and we have
murray with the five dollar super chat
so
sony spent that ps4 profit to buy
third-party scraggly content for ps5
wow don't let microsoft do that
everybody's gonna call foul
shaking my head mm-hmm that's true
yeah then we have picked g with the two
dollar super chat
did no one notice xbox game swapping in
four seconds yeah that yeah yeah very
impressive
very impressive then we have rain g4
with the 2
super chat you guys have rented a
rent-a-knee program
all access knees access these
what if playstation 5 has its own all
access with ps now
nope not about that at all
very good idea um and we have squirrely
dan with the uh five canadian dollar
super chat
oh no they broke king and got him
cursing on the lord
they got kicked in they got kicked out
of his fight
i don't care what the sony event shows
as long as i got my fire extinguisher
with my ps5
i'll be happy to cover with the variable
clock heating stuff
box with the five dollar super chat you
guys are an entertaining group thanks
brother thank you
red i'll let you finish off before i get
my final point out as far as uh the last
one yeah
minnie smith one more oh sweetie okay
yeah we're a king
well when the game doesn't load faster
on the ps5 can you put that ssd on
king's statues
you got something to say before we or
you you oh he's beautiful
honestly i'm a little worried about
miles morales we
we've seen now rats and clank twice
right and it was slated for holiday has
not been shown yet so i'm a little bit
worried about that because that's really
honestly if to be honest that's really
what i want the council for at launch um
i'm into demon souls if that's a thing
but
demon souls is really for the hardcore
you're not getting the casual person
buying a kid you know
the person going on a ps5 at launch has
to be a hardcore person for that type of
game as well
so you know they if it's if it's launch
great if it's not whatever but
honestly i the launch lineup seems yeah
it's very not really that that do sound
on both ends the bolt of the spectrum is
it's the same thing so honestly
i i'm just i really want to make sure
that like if they don't
talk price right if they've been oh lord
which would be bonkers
don't say that so what could you that
would be absolutely
bonkers but then if they don't talk
price then i
any any rumors that we've heard about uh
it not launching simultaneously
worldwide uh it feels like it lends more
credence to that
and to the even more limited a bit
availability of the console approach
unfortunately because i'll be working so
i'm going to miss all that smoke
it's a good look man last point i'll say
is look at the end of the day
i would i need a tear down i need a tear
down i would like to see someone
physically
with the system you know what i'm saying
that would be nice no mock-ups
none of that um yeah i know christopher
hart you mad at us in the chat but
people want to see miles morales that's
not a cinematic trailer
you know what i'm saying and that's all
we want you know what i'm saying we're
not saying it well they're insomniac
just
was uh boasting about the 4k 30
ray tracing mode like i want to see it
right uh i won't play it that way i'll
play it at
dynamic absolutely uh 4k at 60. no rage
i will forego ray tracing on that ps4
he said it's either or why is it either
or
do we get 4k do we get ray tracing what
absolutely
120 frames do we get 30. you know the
way they frame that they frame that
announcement
yeah they said there was a performance
mode basically so
basically that's why they were talking
about the 4k ray tracing
you're going to get a graphics mode and
a performance mode
and i'm pretty sure i would assume based
on uh
an open world of 60 frames that they are
giving you a performance mode with
screen space reflections with no ray
tracing
unless they take the ray tracing and put
it down like quarter
well now this is kind of techy but
let's get it some of the playstation 5
games may use
quarter to half resolution on ray trace
reflections
they're seeing that with gran turismo
which is pushing 120 frames
um so yeah and it's still going to look
great like it's
when you see screen space reflections
it's faked but we still enjoy how games
look
so exactly people man people just get so
hopped up over stuff
games are great games are great games as
long as they're fun and and they always
look great
oh i need to commence i need to slay
them so if you got all the information
with the fake
resolution you gotta let me know i need
this later
80 or 90 of the way there from what i
know and and how i know how insomniac
does things like
there's going to be two modes as far as
i can see one for performance the other
one will be your full
like ray traced with the full uh
resolution
and there will be people who would
rather have a
screenshot amazing game to play at 30
frames but
hey keep in mind when you go into photo
mode it ranks all that stuff up anyway
so played it performance mode then take
your screenshot so you can say look how
great my game looks on twitter but even
that in itself
cole i just want to stop you for a
second is a cause delay the cause of
debate
based on the vagueness of how things are
worded
because you'll see tweets like four
cakes
and then slash 60. so a lot of i've seen
people say oh it's definitely 4k 60.
right and again we got to get a lot of
these answers right because
there's a lot of ambiguity
yeah that's totally normal it sucks
because when shadow of the tomb raider
came out in 2018
uh square enix i can't remember who it
was that made that game
it was another team um but this square
enix tweet said
it runs at 4k and 60. right now you
can't
see that can't say that because these
people fans are running with it thinking
that it's definitely the combination of
both
yeah you're saying it correctly but and
technically you can say 4k and 60 which
means we're gonna have 4k and 60.
but they don't they didn't realize that
their wording
sounds like both exactly at the same
time
i talked about that a couple years ago
if you're gonna say that you have to
have a whole sense behind it which is
kind of
exciting you have to say we're gonna
have two modes one's gonna run at 4k
and the other one right it's frame rate
but when you make a corporate tweet you
want to be clear and concise and short
but then a situation where it's it's
confusing that's why
i say spiderman miles morales is going
to come from two modes
and that is absolutely great it sounds
like they're listening to fans
at first they only acted like here's
your game looking as amazing impossible
at 30.
we're back to juggling again yeah i
i dost my trail yes what would you say
we back the juggling with sony again
yeah
dynamic 4k now we back at it again with
these
checkerboarding dudes man that tweet was
perfectly obtuse like it was purposely
obtuse just for that reason because they
know they
couldn't say 4k 60 ray tracing they knew
oh well that's not something they can do
so you know
you omit the stuff that that's not going
to put you in a in a nice lighting yeah
listen i get it i get it we just got to
say look just wanted to tear down
you know i just want to see the game
playing moving and then
when is it launching you know what i'm
saying that that's it demon soul we'll
see if it's going to be there any little
surprise thing
um me selfishly you know i hope that
ghost mode you know goes to shiva get
that little four player joint we know
a little graphical fidelity from ps5 you
know maybe get some enhancements
there i want to know some other games
get some enhancements because one thing
i do like that they're doing
is a thing like osushima and last of us
where
hopefully come around launch that those
existing games get cool features that's
the only thing i'm upset with xbox i had
this conversation with ran
is that i i love we're getting gears 5
at 120
that's dope but how cool would it have
been if there would have been like a dlc
content that launches for gears 5 right
in conjunction so now you got new
content to show off
these new features and i just wish a lot
even the forza horizons all these games
that we know are gonna get enhanced
would be so cool if they had content
right around that time to take advantage
of it as well so you can see newer stuff
but yeah i mean look that's what i got
solving super chat said let's get about
here man it's late
right uh we have sinjitsu shades with
the firewall
that oled crew assembled we're going to
use my
kitchen table sir i gave you some
influence of motivation
gamer by choice the five dollar super
chat king should put the xbox
uh series s and x on the statue table of
the week of release
smoking mirrors and ratchet and clank
those worlds uh will be instant
instantaneously warping through will not
be on
we'll be on rails glorified unexplorable
background
wow the disrespect is that true i mean
there's some gameplay where it looks
like you can just point in an area and
transport
which is kind of like a a leash mechanic
in a lot of games where yeah
where you pull the leash and it takes
you up there quicker but the exact king
is smiling right now
you are feeding king right now so what
they do is instead
of um instead of trans
doing like a transversal up to the the
uh
the grappling point it's actually
pulling uh
and insomniac developer explained that
um
i'm not sure if it was insomniac they
said that what they do is they basically
take a
2d slice a 2d cross section of the game
and they pull you into that and then
snap you into
that instance in the 3d world so um
[Music]
yeah it is kind of a it is a cool trick
that they're doing
but i assume you can pick any grappling
point quote unquote
and transport yourself into that world
but there are some other place where you
go into a different universe
i don't know if that's on rails but it
is the only game
now i'm not downplaying it because this
is the only game and i like the ratchet
and clank games
this is the only one that actually says
we're doing something that it
conventional hard drive can't do
and that's really cool yeah yeah she
just fed kig with
his uh analysis i said that before the
lasso button
oh you did and i'll bet your people got
really
livid with him yes but it actually is
like a grappling hook
and with with newly
designed games like i mean i've played
uh just cause three and four where you
can grapple like 700 feet
and it pulls you uh with a blur effect
like
racing you up to a helicopter and
and that's on an xbox 360. you know you
could do that just cause two
so uh this is a different thing though
but it does kind of look like that
did we get forte and then the rest yeah
we got a gaming fourteen
five ten dollar five dollar super chat
until cod and 2k go next gen only
you won't see a system completely pull
ahead uh whoever has the marketing
rights at that point will dominate the
jet
okay that's fantastic then we have
perfect shogun with the two dollar super
shout out to christopher hart and god
fall gameplay in the bushes
let me get let me get the ghost man
shout out to luke lord
no shame tcl team i feel you brother
i'll feel you bro we still got love you
know tcl get your head
rapping hard you know what is it so like
that's it man ran i think i had to go
wrench through there man let's be about
to get out yeah the final thoughts yeah
yeah
i'm still here yeah we're about to wrap
up just one knowing any file thoughts on
that last thing cause we outta here
um no i don't really have any final
thoughts i think i'm pretty good
cool cool good on it except you know
what uh screw remedy in control
you can throw them in the bushes all the
way don't bully the publishers rand
yeah that's what somebody told me when i
said hey look look at what cyberpunk is
doing or what game was it recently that
said it was getting i can't remember
but i said hey i remember remember i
remember colt when you and like dealer
and fonz were all
asking for ubisoft to to put 60 frames
mode and
everybody like there are some people
being like stop being mean or you stop
stop oh
yeah and you're like man no these
systems can do it and then what do you
know
four okay well yeah i'll take some of
these real men
i'll say something real messy a king
might like but i think the xbox guys
more than anyone
anyone uh got spider-man miles morales
from ratchet and clank
60 frames this it almost seems like that
because i talked to so many people on
social media they were like
look how amazing it looks and it uses
the ssd and it looks great at 30 frames
looks better than anything xbox ever
made
and i'm like i'm just asking for 60
frames
and you know and insomniac and stepped
up and said hey our
both of our games are going to have a
performance mode i like that this is
where
and cold already knows this is where
i'll disagree oh
i think those are already in in in the
in the right yes
of course of course yes they were
already in the works
and valhalla i also think valhalla was
already in the works to run at 60 frames
and as far as uv sauce is concerned
there the reason why it took so long for
them to stay is probably because they
were trying to
make sure everything was good to go
because ubisoft does not want a game
dropping down to 47 frames on a new
console
and uh i'm sure that insomniac had both
their games running just great at 60 and
they would just wait until everything
was ready
wouldn't it be funny if like uh
christopher hart shout out to
christopher hart big playstation fan
wouldn't it wouldn't it be hilarious if
like we all got playstation 5's but he
like overslept
yeah i woke up and was like oh man i
missed my chance and
we were on twitter
i really hope that we can all get the
consoles day one and
i hope that all works out it's just the
the
uh demand for consoles even current
garbage consoles right now
are you getting vitamin stores and uh
just means when next generation drops
you better
like be freaking punching a hole through
your phone trying to get that thing
pre-ordered because it's gonna be rough
oh yeah get on deck y'all get on well
you know um sad to say
some people just ain't gonna have it
that day
and when you don't have it that day
i'm gonna have it and i'm gonna laugh at
it
i'm gonna have your boo-boo in my house
and i'm gonna
so apparently insomniac is immune to uh
big rona because there's no way miles is
getting delayed according to some
hope they share the cure wow the arrow
the arrow channel
360 do the same thing as ratchet and
clank with portal i wasn't impressed
a great show i'm laughing so
stitch with the five dollar super chat
all i have to say is that i'm going to
save my money on that ps5 and get me a
second oled wow
jd gamer with the five dollar super chat
respect to the iron lords i'll catch the
show on replay
no doubt look let's get up all right no
i'll people oh
i'm going to game stop on pre-order day
and coughing up a storm in line i'm
getting married yo yo
[Applause]
going to show up to pick up his
pre-order and there's going to be bars
across
gamestop when it shuts down
there is a little uh controversy about
that people are talking about should i
pre-order gamestop in case they go out
of business they're closing a ton of
stores
um somebody like matt piscotella maybe
said don't worry about that that's
pre-order stuff goes through okay a
third party and your stuff would be
honored but everybody could be safe yeah
we gotta be safe hey real quick
real quick guys the panel where are you
pre-ordering
like does does everybody have like a uh
go-to
because i you know i was thinking should
i go amazon should i go xbox.com
um i'm thinking best buy from me but
what are you guys thinking
amazon's best buy all the windows open
yeah i'm thinking amazon but i just feel
like amazon's gonna be slammed
i mean amazon i don't know i might just
pre-order
a system at each each one just to make
sure that's how you get it
like i'll order one from amazon and
microsoft store and best buy
and the only reason why i'm picking best
buy i just love their policy if
something go wrong
like you literally just go in there they
just give you a brand new one and you
like
do they really oh bro yeah we're gonna
talk about the hustle with the deal they
give you they give you your money back
bro all your cash back whatever you pay
for a point of purchase they'll give you
that back they'll be like just go in
there and get it if
it depreciates over time nothing yeah
yeah
one of my controllers when the rubber
thing that the first one remember when
it was the issue
and i'd go into them they're trying to
explain a big look you see because this
is what they'd be like we don't care
about that sir
um there's a brand new one in the box
you just bring that to the front sir
you're already down with the geek squad
whatever the plan it is yeah and you're
good to go
and i'm like oh for real thank you is
that what you got with the oled
ah yes of course
yes anything goes wrong you know they
say yeah right
anything anything go wrong like the you
know the next uh the next up
version comes out yeah something might
go wrong with the new version come out
listen to what happens with that okay
with the television
yeah that doesn't work that way oh damn
they send them to your house if they
can't fix it after
two times then listen it happened to my
samsung upstairs
they came to my house the guy fixed the
panel
and left i thought i was getting a whole
brand new tv
he said thank you guys you see some
dudes showing plumbers crack
yes exactly that's exactly what
so you know what you have you have to do
that panel extra dirty that's
don't forget leave those those
espn stickers going they'll just take
this
i don't know how this happened what i'm
gonna do this year i'm gonna do my
patent move
i'm ordering two from everybody
all the extra ones is gonna be on ebay
for two thousand five hundred dollars
dude i'm doing you dirty all right so
i'm gonna let you know right now if you
look at my twitter timeline
you saw what happened last year you saw
what happened with the x's you saw what
happened with the playstations
you saw what happened with the regular
xboxes i'm doing the same exact thing
this year
and if those playstations are super hard
to get i'm gonna make sure i get five
and then going for five grand each one
i'll let you boy
i'm trying to get it come on i'm trying
to get that
with the playstation 5 showcase now
announced what do you think is most
important
for sony to accomplish in competition
with the xbox series s
and x the choices are a at minimum
standard playstation 5 must match the
series
x at 500. b
playstation 5 digital must be 400 or
less to compete with the series s
c must reveal miles morales gameplay
and more launch titles or d i don't care
but if i see
another ps5 render or mock-up without a
physical system
throw that release date in the bushes
shout out to all the lords shout out to
lord
red outdoor and colt eastwood coming
through that fresh new nfl friendly time
yo shout out colt for coming dude i mean
this podcast was as long as an nfl game
right through that do that you get the
whole kit kaboodle in you here
so salute to y'all man let's start with
coke first pleasure to have you to run
brother long overdue we got to bring in
more
so that's all me you know what i'm
saying but salute to you 100k
continuing with the tremendous videos
love hearing
your thoughts on ideas shout out for you
also keeping a dealer to behave on rdx i
always respect you
where you go i love what you're feeling
yeah i love when you say that you always
get deal with the behavior so salute to
you man and keep the ascension where can
the five people find you
what you got going on sir well i just
want to say that like
being in this community and making
friends with people like amazing people
that
i work with and that support me and that
i support like the rdx podcasts
iron lords all these other podcasts i've
been able to check out
it's been a really great thing and
people are amazing
and this is a time when i spend more
time talking to you guys
yeah then i get to talk to people that
are my friends that actually
live around me because it's just the way
it is
so that means a lot to me you can find
me at colt eastwood
on twitter and xbox live and playstation
and steam and the switch
now you can find me everywhere and it's
been a really really i mean
rand will agree with me it's been a
really great year
to create content on youtube and
reach out to people and hear and share
the stuff that
we're getting excited about and just
remember that you know most of
everybody is really excited to game
they're not really here to argue and
those that there's just that small
community
and ignorance and cold east would uh he
doesn't uh
hide his games played in his uh trophies
and his gamer score either you know so
yeah i'm like a level seven or eight on
playstation i've got
a hundred and twenty thousand some gamer
score which isn't bad for a guy with
kids
uh i don't know i like the hobby a lot i
love
doing the video stuff being on this
podcast is freaking hilarious and thank
you thanks guys i really appreciate it
absolutely keep up the fantastic work
your work is exceptional i just love to
see the ascension
you know me and rand speak about you all
the time i mean it's really high
quality stuff so i love to see you out
there and again the 100k but wow like
salute to you bro that is
tremendous work and it it goes to show
you putting it in man you put it in so
salute
to the cup my man it's a little brother
we got to bring in more
and of course everyone's favorite
non-filmic
insider the man with all the knowledge
and all the smoke
that's going on red my bro in the
building man good to have you brother
always a pleasure
with you guys it was fun being on man
fun being on although i am a little bit
tired now it's like a
three-hour podcast you enjoyed yourself
frank come on
it was great it was a great time
i think i might have to go take a nap
a little tired here but um yeah it's
always great to uh podcast with you guys
um hopefully you know when we don't wait
another year
yeah uh for you to invite me on now
you know that you must hear the lord
unlocked i know i got i got bougie
whatever as you know
i'm b lester y'all y'all get the vip
oh my god
anything else going on certainly any
video anything we need to look out for
oh yeah yeah my i i'm not like cold cold
makes his videos like the day before
right he puts on this huge production
coat will tell you like i'll just like
make a video off off a whim
i'd be like call to making a video and
he's like what what what it what about
i'm like i don't know something i just
thought of 10 minutes
absolutely so i'll probably i'll have
some videos this week
um just not sure what they would be yet
but i'll think of something well keep up
the good work man always i call you the
the conscious of the community like you
always bring that nice balanced
perspective
i know people give you craps oh he's a
fan but now you call it straight down
the line and i
always love i i tell you this all the
time like you're one of the first that
when
you know whether it be your video or
your xbox 2 like i'm racing to see what
you got to say
always bounce perspective always fair
keep it real continue doing what you're
doing sir i love it and keep up the
health stuff i like when i hear that
from you that's good we want you around
i like something here it is i drink like
three propels during the show man
get that rice going get that we're gonna
talk offline but yeah
but salute to my bro red you know say
keep it up bro and of course so we
missed addicted to anybody good he did
pull up
man shout out to out of getting his rest
we will get trucker hat addict
in here with this pharmaceutical it's
going down he ain't getting
loose so but salute to addict i know you
have to work to double lord
playstation nation's own raising money
i see you late on the podcast yes with
soft talks that we like talk that talks
off
tell em if you believe that i have
something special for you coming up
but um of course man big shout out to
colt and rand like you guys
as much content as you guys put out
you really have to have a thick skin on
youtube because
it's just you can't avoid being called
this of that and
guys continue to do everything with a
smile on your face
and continue to put out the content and
show people that their opinions of you
are just
i don't know where they come from
because you got to be crying to see
these two guys
call things down everybody has their
preferences when you know we're human
beings we have our preferences
at the end of the day though you got
both of you guys call everything really
down the middle
and it's ridiculous to hear anything
else other than that so
i take solace in knowing that those guys
hide their phones from their wives or
girlfriends because
they knew that they were calling like
xbox or game other gamers like foul
names because
they like another platform i know that
they
oh
they said they don't count but anyway so
um
yeah you guys you can catch me you know
i'm going to work right now but i can
actually have lunch with my wife before
oh my
and god course with all the damn
smoke lord king
had a lot to say today preaching the
word book of acts came out a few times
today
we're going to find people find you what
you got going on sir first and foremost
well i had to do it my man addict wasn't
there so i had to hold down the phone
for my man at it
look you know it's funny actually i put
it i set an alarm and everything but i
got home around like
9 30. i woke up it was 1 30 i was like
yeah
yeah and my phone's probably been going
off for two hours
shout out to atl he said the first
interrupt per second y'all you
stupid i gotta i gotta say um
the holy trinity is a cult
deal and ran i've always i always tell
you um i
really really watch every video you guys
put out
so to have uh two of my holy trinities
here
and and to meet one in person and he
live up to everything that i uh you know
hear from his video and his personality
is he's truly a nice guy he really calls
it down the middle
and you know i don't i don't ever read
his comments because
it doesn't even make any sense because
his videos are self-explanatory if you
get
anything if you extrapolate anything
from his videos other than what he's
giving you that's on you
that's not on call
[Music]
i i i just got today's age when i found
out rand makes videos
ryan loves to smoke i just don't like
the smoke yeah i love to play in the pig
pen like me
i like doing it quietly yes
yes see colt like to keep his hands
clean
oh believe me trust me he he'd
definitely be talking though
on the phone no the difference is rand
hides in the bushes and watches the
drama from oh
yeah i'm in the bushes
he's eating bon bons in the bushes
watching the drama knows what will be
going on inside
yeah people like yeah every time every
time ryan's like cold
oh man you got to see what they're
saying about your brothers
as a good friend why don't you go to bat
for me something oh no no i'm not
kidding
uh king thank you so much when you said
the trifecta like
dealer and rand are true true friends
and meeting you guys awesome i can't
wait
to meet up again like just yeah i
actually spent some time talking to
cognito person you and i king talked for
quite a while
yeah at the last e3 and uh to meet attic
and you guys like yeah that means a lot
like
really really really good people and uh
let the three percent say what they're
going to say
you know yeah well i don't care about
that um
um but uh this wednesday yes sir
if you guys thought if
you had an inkling of what was going on
today if you thought that was
oh if there's a slip
up on wednesday i look at you
someone give me a rating man how bad was
king today
i see a slip if i see a dance move if
y'all don't do what y'all supposed to do
y'all know how i do on these live shows
yes sir
i want you to come through with all the
smoke
sony
because i'm gonna tell you right now
remember christopher hart the last show
you said oh no not like this
i forgot that bro so
this week i'm gonna be in rare form
and i'm telling you you're not gonna
like me
oh my god yes we will be doing a live
reaction okay there's a lot of tins in
that chat king
that's a lot he was 10 out of 10 today
he was he was preaching to work it's
going to be fun man look
so bad this show i'm going to get out of
here for a rain she starts yelling at me
yeah yeah yeah
but everybody we got sunday football
next week same thing we're back
at 11 again you know what i'm saying and
then where's my outro what's going on
here
but look man everybody look enjoy your
sunday
you know saying get this football going
on we'll be back next week again 11am
eastern for the remainder of the year
we're gonna leave y'all with this promo
and next week we'll also have some new
promotional stuff that's all baby uh
alluding to so everyone enjoy yourself
peace hi i'm lord king david of iron
lords podcast
and we're bringing to you an exciting
new giveaway
this giveaway is like none other we'll
be giving away
a xbox series x that's right
you heard me right the brand new console
launching from microsoft this year
well this is how you're able
to be part of that giveaway there's two
ways
to get your name thrown in the hat
for the raffle one become a member
of the realm that's hit that join button
hit that joy button you hit that join
button down at the bottom
and you can become a member and also
another way is by becoming a patreon
member
so you can be part of the realm as well
now this is brought to you by cat
daddy fat stacks a member
and lord of the realm a very generous
person
that's in our community and this
community
is beautiful so remember
you can have one entry by hitting that
join button
and becoming a member of the realm and
also you can have another entry
by being a patreon now you said king
what if i'm a member of both well your
name gets thrown in the hat
two times so please like follow and
subscribe
join or become a patreon member
or become both and your name
is in the hat to get that
xbox series x
as to who did that for you sweepstakes
this is wonderful this is something that
i'm sure that you will enjoy
oh man